two hi everybody it's Friday which is
usually you know the day that we like to
do fun episodes here on after dark
Friday but today we're going to not have
fun we're going to try to do a serious
interview uh with Oliver tree who's
sitting at the maximum distance away
from me possible he has a history I
don't know if you guys can see the
distance but he has a violent history in
the studio Ethan come on man trying to
explain why we're trying to have peace
here and I feel like you're trying to
start something and this the show has
even begun yet I just there's just some
disclaimers and then we can move on
amicably the last time Oliver was here
he result he resulted in physical
violence I do not remember that I don't
recall well it's on video
okay and um so I have him at an arms
length here actually like 10 arms
lengths so you told me that was you told
me that was a protocol for Co
no no it's not it's not that was a lie
it's cuz I don't want you near
me And so as long as you don't pass that
halfway
line then we're going to be fine I would
never do that the minute you pass that
halfway line Oliver and I'm just saying
this for my protection and my wife's
protection she's here she wasn't here
last time and she's pregnant by the way
I'm so excited con to You Make Some
Noise no
no I mean yes but hold on I'm not done
talking I mean cheers obviously for the
baby you know not trying to dampen that
but I'm just saying this is for my
protection and this is for your
protection so for your protection you
have put your pregnant wife closer to me
I don't understand yes what kind of
system do you have in place because you
wouldn't hit her okay I would not but I
would never hit you either that's see
now that's just not true there's a video
that's
factual why don't we all right who's
using the sound effects you is this
supposed to be a serious interview yeah
let the behind us go on with a fresh
start today well people are going to be
like why are they so far apart that's
just what I was going to say it's like a
rest it's like a little bit of a
restraining order like but it's like 3
feet it's just a buffer just think of it
as a three foot restraining order okay
okay okay if we can just avoid all clown
sounds anything that's related that's C
that's really up to you I prefer to just
keep it serious you know I wanted to
have a serious interview obviously let's
both respect this time she's a mogul
she's busy she's designing she's
manufacturing making incredible clothing
garments Make some
noise I always respect her time though
that's the difference so I just in
respect for heila and everything that
she's doing that's incredible work uh
let's just keep it nice let's keep it
we're going to do we're going to do a
really nice professional inter agree you
know I saw you on steo doing like a
serious interview and I was like what I
have so much respect for steo clearly
because when I watched you on his he was
just being like a normal guy and I was
like I've never seen this side of him
yeah dude and I didn't appreciate that
well you know what me and sta went
camping two days ago you never invited
me camping yeah bro I'm why would I
invite you camp you even invited me over
to your house I've met you like 30 times
and I'm still waiting for a hangout
invite maybe a dinner have you never
been to our house for real no h you're
surprised you're never in town you're in
like for one day and then I'm going on a
world tour or I'm going to like Serbia
to take care to like exploit
their cheap
well I'm I'm not going to get there
because this supposed to be a very
polite serious interview and I will say
this I do travel I do not live anywhere
and my goal is for the next three months
is to hit all seven continents you want
to come over tonight that's amazing I'm
going to Bali Indonesia
tonight there you go it's not funny this
is a serious thing you could literally
come over
tonight yeah what an interesting timing
you finally get the invite and I happen
to be going
oning yes continent what you say on a
seven tour well it's not all a tour some
of it's for myself but a lot of it is
tours but realistically I am just trying
to hit all seven continents in the next
three months and I've been to six so far
but I wanted to do one picture is you
have a lot of fans in
Antarctica it's funny you say that I've
been talking with a few scientists and
there's not many people out there so in
the grand scheme of things yeah there is
a lot gu there's only like 13 people who
live there so if three of them are a
fans those are good numbers yeah that's
true they probably relate to the new
album like all alone yes for sure
probably have the same amount of fans in
in anarctica as you do in other
continents where does this hostility
come from I thought we were actually
going to do a serious interview me on
here I'm try to I was just so so here
you are being serious on stea I just
clicked over to a random spot parents
the night of the burn
so I had been kind of doing my own thing
seeing like the concerts and stuff on my
own and like the last night was the
night of I just didn't understand and
then the title is Oliver tree breaks
character I was like wow that's a pretty
good title yeah
I mean you know the thing is I've always
looked up to steo and he's always been
such a big inspiration for me so like
when I really respect someone obviously
I'm going to come as myself right and
today I've been prepared to do so but
I'm getting a lot of just resistance
right now okay so here's what we're
going to do I'm going to need like 10
minutes yeah to just talk about like our
tickets are about to go on sale 10
minutes it goes live in 10 minutes okay
what about my tickets going live they go
live pretty soon here mine go live in 11
minutes we can talk about those we can
show that yeah okay cool all right
that's a deal so but I mean feel free to
chime in just I'll chime in I think we
don't do the tickets thing how about how
was that no I didn't well okay and no I
mean you can chime in what's the tickets
for so we're doing our live show
everybody's been talking about YouTube's
hottest night wow finally here the
tickets are going on sale would alliver
be invited to our show cuz I again I've
tried to get him to our shows but you
come to our show orever ever and I'm
like that's clearly budget what the fee
for me to play yeah it's 2000 I didn't I
didn't ask you to play St high and
you're the fee is only 200 grand for my
normal performance fee now for a friend
I would be willing to make a deal for
you I said I don't 195 I said I don't
even want you to play music just come
say hi I know and that's there's a fe
there's a different feed for that whoa
that's is that you or is that both of
you combined oh that's me that's me
Ethan Klein the host we're doing the
streamy Live December 17th of the Dolby
Theater and I'll have you know this
Dolby Theater is where they host the
Academy Awards that is not a coincidence
we will be crazy we will be um having
the hottest night in YouTube's history
guys it's all happening tickets are on
sale for members bring that countdown
back up we'll be doing a sending out a
code for members on Discord and uh the
creators the community Tab and the
membership tab uh both tabs on YouTube
friend keep your eyes open there's 3,300
tickets available and I personally think
that you know it's double what we did
last time I think it's going to open up
to non-members probably tomorrow
although you all have a different
opinion honestly I don't think it's
going to make it there I hope it does
but I don't think it's going to think
it's going to sell out before then 2
minutes wait you hope that it doesn't
sell out AB oh I hope it sells out but I
feel like you know for everyone it'd be
nice if nonmembers got an opportunity at
least I agree yeah but how big is this
you 3,300 you never been to the Dolby no
that's amazing 3,300 it's like a huge
theater in La bro that's crazy you never
played there no I never have I never
heard of it huh really oh it's where
they have the Academy Awards what's the
biggest theater You' played in La just
the shrine well I played other ones
bigger spaces as special guests but the
shrine would be for my own show what's
the shrine how many seats is that like
5,000 really that's great good for you
that was years ago did you f was it sold
out or no we sold it out really yeah how
about that how about that so what's the
show entail what is this so yeah we're
what we're going to be doing our normal
kind of live show stick and we'll be
doing the streamy the steamies not the
no legal association with the streaming
none at all it's a it's an award show
where we honor the great in digital
media oh amazing so I'll probably get an
award
then frankly you you the you might sweet
it's December 17th oh will you be in
this continent I'm going to be in I'm
going to be in Argentina
maybe get a zoom call uh it depends what
time it's going to be at cuz I have to
look at the time 7 p.m. range 700 p.m. I
wonder what that is an Argentinian time
okay well let's figure that out do you
guys have any other predict you all are
feeling very confident that it's going
to sell immediately but I don't two
minutes I'm more skeptical than the rest
of these yeah I'm not saying two minutes
but there's that would be like a
sizable number of members last time we
sold out in seconds no yes last time it
was like
3 minutes I I'm just saying I think it's
easy to sometimes forget how big our
family is you know they're powerful
they're strong and they come in waves
they come in waves they coming in waves
and a lot of the memberships are couples
too so time say by two that's that's
true these people aren't coming by
themselves right most of them anyway
just the really sad
ones right which we love them and I want
to be their friend we what's wrong with
being sad and lonely AB abely nothing I
want them to come to our show and make
new friends that's the thing and that's
why my shows are so great is because
they're filled with so many H3 fans yeah
that you look at those crowds they're
covered in Teddy fresh and I tell people
where your best Teddy fresh that's what
I always tell them and a lot of people
have met new friends and even I I talked
with mold they met their future husband
or wife thank you man at the show to and
their fans of the AG podcast make
actually cool you know what you're not
joking I'm not joking and I heard that
to because listen it takes a special
type of person to be a fan of this show
let's just be real about let's be real
same with to be a fan of Oliver treat
right so we have that in common and so
you know double special if you're
willing to put that out there publicly
like hey people going public hey I'm a
fan of Oliver treat like ridicule you're
cut you're putting yourself out there
and you're going to lose a lot of people
in the process absolutely especially
being an H3 do you that's that's not
that's not untrue do you actually think
that about your music of course I bro
it's not a public opinion that you want
to be on that side of oh he makes good
music for Who that's what they say
really but they're not like you're not
like offensive they might be like he's
not my cup of tea but no they go yo you
listen to that fat they say no wait what
did you say they call me fat they say I
me too you look skinny man you guys look
great you lock way I did I've been
working out training what's your what's
your regiment regiment 5 days a week
lifting different you know you work on
the legs Monday Tuesday core that was
unappropriate Z hold on how are we going
to have a serious interview if we have
was just opening up about weight Oliver
yeah remember last time you called me
fat when I came on your show let let me
defend you Zach that was inappropriate
we're having a serious apologies
apologies you yeah I called did I call
you fat I don't remember yeah you did
you said you've been I've been getting
skinnier you've been getting fatter
right right now we're both getting Fair
it was a good one you got me with the
Zinger I'll give it to you and I was I
was eating six Michelin restaurants a
week and I just got as big as I could
and I got it out of my system I'm really
proud of myself because I did it
naturally I didn't use any kind of like
things to help me get there there's
nothing wrong with that but I would felt
really good to just do it myself and
just kick my ass so so hold on you're
doing weightlifting are you doing cardio
and stuff yeah personal trainer TR yeah
amazing trainer guy or girl Guy and um I
I was just taking care of my vessel you
know and I got so fat and I I enjoyed it
I raveled in I was eating as many
snicker bars as I could trying to get as
big as I could and at a certain point I
was like cool I got it out of my system
time to Redial things back oh you just
went all out I did I was like pushing
myself how many pieces of pizza can I
fit in my mouth at a time for what
purpose I was just testing to see my
body's limitation okay like a like a
Roman athlete well I was deciding it's
like for this album cycle do I want to
like lean into the heavier side you know
so if you look at the original album
cover that I made I literally have the
hugest double chin and then I retook the
picture and redid it later and I lost
significant weight well I'm happy for
that's always a good thing I love that
you know and um I mean you're an extreme
athlete with the scootering and stuff
I'm surprised that you're just not right
cuz you do all those stunts right I do
but the thing that makes it hard is that
since you're traveling constantly it's
not like I scooter regularly and after
my big crash 2018 that was something
that I didn't really do as much after
coid but when was this that was so okay
I will set the record straight with this
that isn't entirely natural there was a
six-month period where I did steroids
what oh you were on that liver King well
no I was I mean technically speaking
it's it if they tested me for STS I
wouldn't have shown any signs uh it's
the same stuff that a lot of these
athletes use but I was using
performance-enhancing drugs dude look at
your titties man they're M before after
the Snicker bars this was before the
Snicker bar I've gotten fat many
different times so that was in in Co I
had lost a lot of weight training with
the trainer and then I wanted to take it
to the next level and um that's when I
got some we call it juice yeah we call
it juice for sure well anyway um listen
it's great to talk to you we have 2
minutes 30 seconds left here um tickets
are about to go out my friends what
skill at the showest night s me S me a
guy who's knocking I don't want to buy a
ticket I'm not interested sell me the
show last time it was all of our like
show Friends oh that's funny I didn't
get invited that's yes you did bro no I
did not you said pay me 100,000 I didn't
say that you're like said 200 that's the
current fee okay so even better no but
if I was just to show up as a friend 50
Grand okay well I don't pay my other
friends to come just so you know they
just like to be included you know right
right but um I can't tell you much other
than it's going to be YouTube's hottest
night I love it and I'm so excited to
get nominated for an award what is my
nomination um let's see where would I
fit in in this whole did Oliver have any
moments this year like he had that was
the Tik Tok thing this year or last
year don't want to see you want to see
isn't it funny how like it did so much
better when they like you couldn't even
tell it was your voice it did like way
better exactly it was way easier to get
behind a song you couldn't tell it was
my voice was that what did it on a
serious question did it surprise you how
well that that song went crazy right the
remix changed my life yeah yeah it was
surprising the reality is that um you
know people love fast things nowadays
we're living in such a crazy attention
are you being serious right now what I
don't know cuz I thought we were doing a
serious interview and sometimes I feel
like you're doing stick of what you're
like oh we live in a fast-paced world
that's why people liked it dude have you
been I mean we all have ADHD on some
level if you're on Tik Tok which okay go
ahead sorry I just curious if you I
don't know that seems like a weird thing
to say I think I had a pretty straight
shooter answer okay go ahead well I was
just saying we live in a very fast-paced
society and so when we have you know
quick paced things you have fast the
songs get faster songs get you know it's
over like for example the album I just
made I've got songs that are 1 minute
and 18 seconds
long that's just the way I thought felt
perfect consuming things that are just
shorter made it doesn't need to be two
hours the album's like 30 minutes long
it's like maybe they'll listen to it
maybe not but is it really I listen to
it it felt longer than that I like it I
don't know if that's the insult or a
compliment I lik that album I thought it
was I thought it was a lot of fun thank
you man I did I definitely recommend
everyone to check out and since it's
only 30 minutes I mean what do you have
to lose I know 30 minutes of your life
which is a lot well depends what you're
doing that's true oh well guys we have 5
seconds left tickets are about to go out
two one although this is on a delay of
about a minute so by the time you're
hearing this it will check Discord check
the community tab the post is up put the
passcode is out my friends that's right
it's all happening so I will uh I will
keep you a prais Ethan as uh as things
are the Dolby Theater that's right
December 17th the
hottest night of the year night it's
YouTube's htest night we're going to who
knows what what hot celebrities we might
have
caman I was thinking peanut butter
obviously obviously we will not
enforce a dress code but I thought it
would be fun because it's YouTube's
hottest night we should encourage all of
our fans to dress up right oh that'd be
fun why don't you make it a fancy night
I like that that'd be fun I'm definitely
going to be are you sure you know you
want I'm going to be in Argentina a but
I love the idea and I would love to
maybe call in on a zoom call or
something maybe I can promote something
in the middle of yeah I know I mean as
long as you can promote and then it's
good to call but anyway guys check the
the uh the password let's get it going
my friends it's all happening right now
right now at the H stre podcast that's
right all right so
um yeah so I was trying to find can you
guys find the song page cuz I actually
just wanted to check act the views and
reach of that song it was crazy right
you mean like that the stats for that
sound or whatever yeah like this yeah I
don't want to see you
again and I never want to see you and I
to see you again like that
mhm do you when you do perform that song
do you do it the fast version do my
faleto let me hear
it I don't really want to do it right
now I'm not getting my full rate so
that's all you're going to get that's a
little teaser for the the whole concert
I'm putting on and the whole
tour show let me ask you this when you
have a huge Tik Tok hit like that do you
see it trickle into other parts of your
career like people start listening more
on YouTube people start going to your
shows for change stuff like that yeah
the thing is that a lot of people it's
been hard for them because they'll get
one crazy Tik Tok moment and they don't
have much of a catalog right so there
has to be something there and something
that's already resonated on some level
so the first time around I had Life Goes
On which I remember you did a beautiful
rendition of
and big mouth yeah big mouth you still
doing that yeah yeah always that's the
that's a trademark works like a charm um
I had to stop moving my mouth so big
because my TM I had TMJ problems so I'm
wait did did that really happen yeah you
like inj and I was had ringing in my ear
sh you were getting problems yeah so you
don't do the big mouth anyway I can't do
the Big Mouth by signature huh oh no do
you feel that's affecting your oh yes
sales are going
down I can still do it no but like um
okay so so has Tik Tok really been kind
of instrumental in uh it's been yeah
there's been a big uh push I think what
I found is that when I have a in my
career I basically will milk it you know
I'll milk it dry a lot of people will
say oh man like this dude sold out but
the truth is I feel so lucky that I can
finally have something that finally
connects cuz I've had one Monumental
failure after another which isn't I'm
not saying an oh poor me blah blah blah
but I'm thinking like you know
everything I do feels like a failure and
then you have these one or two moments
maybe four in my career right had
Monumental success and that's when I
only use the word success I don't use it
lightly but those moments of success
allow me to be able to financially take
the risks to do take the chances like my
cowboy album A lot of people were saying
oh he sold out he made life goes on
milked it and then ran it to the ground
but really I put out this country album
that was for myself and it was such a
Financial Risk and lost tons of money in
the label was not really unhappy with me
and it was one of those things where I
really put my heart and soul into
something that was for me and it's it's
funny because I would milk something
else so I could take the creative risk
in another way can I suggest maybe
making for them for who of just the
people that like your music I know it's
hard right but that's what I did with
this new album I went back to the first
album style where it's very diverse very
eclectic and tried to make something
that I wanted something that they wanted
something for us together so I'm I am
trying to make sure that they feel like
that I am listen listening to them but I
also want to know that like or I want
them to know hey I have to make music
for all the other people who aren't fans
the old stuff exists and if they like
that they can go to that you know just
like your old videos or your podcast if
people don't like the
new episode or the New Direction it's
going they can still explore the old
stuff enjoy that you
know
[Music]
um I think that's such a smart thing I
don't think anyone should be afraid to
ride something into the ground I feel
like when you get that hot moment you
have to make the absolute best of it and
just I I agree with that philosophy it's
a smart approach when you might you
don't know when it's going to come back
around and you got it's probably never
going to come back around so I live that
way I'm like from it this might be the
only opportunity in my entire existence
to have this happen and I did that with
life goz on I was like I'm just going to
ride this out because I've worked so
hard to this point to have a moment
that's even remotely close to what that
so how do you milk it like you just post
endless videos you burn it yourself
basically you get as many remixes as you
can you just like my Spotify was like 25
to 50 remixes depending on those two
songs and you go to other artists you're
like let's remix this Ian people are
already remixing it they make them
official ones or whatever it is but it's
like I don't have to do extra work
really I'm just like okay I have these
viral videos I'm going to put the song
in the background cuz the truth is like
it's sad but so much of being an artist
now has nothing to do with the actual
art it's like 90% promotion and whether
you want to call performing making music
videos or doing like Tik toks that's all
promotion in some form or another so
really you know I have to recognize that
that's the job of it make that's sick
Bro I'm sorry to interrupt but I just
want people to know how fast it happened
we sold out congrats
GG that is amazing thank you guys I am
appreciative
AIG Dan was Dan was being respectful and
waiting for him to finish but I'm like
no it's a flex how fast that
happened I did not tell him to do that
sorry congrats that's so amazing that
was sick what you were saying so I think
what we're going to do next is we're
going to put up my tickets and we should
get them to do the same thing so we're
going to see how you guys can out we got
a world tour here so hold on before we
do that I want to say that's crazy are
you sure it's sold out yeah I'm I'm
talking to our promoter it's officially
sold out
congratulations % minute cuz there's
only like how many people are watching
right now that means 10% bought it that
doesn't make any sense these numbers do
not add up yeah it's 34 B did you guys
bring into the chat that's what I'm
wondering well people people can buy
multiple tickets there was a four ticket
cap and so probably a lot of people
bought them for them and their
or friends or whatever and those are
called scalpers Dan or that we deal with
that in the music business theoretically
we uh have some protections against that
but uh and we'll see I mean it always
happens there's only so much do you are
you Pro or anti- scalping or do they
they don't even bother with your show
well dude I've seen tickets of my shows
that are $1,000 so it's not a weird
thing I'm like who's going to waste a
th000 bucks I feel bad just being taken
advantage of right I mean that's the
whole that's the whole aftermarket how
come you guys didn't go for a bigger
room 3,300 is bigger than just sold it
out in like 2 minutes but I don't know
that I don't know the last one I could
tell you I could do the math for you so
last these numbers are not good last
time it was half this size so we doubled
it should have quadrupled it so what do
you think I should be doing I could I
can work as an agent for you guys for a
small percentage it's do you think do
you think we could sell out the do you
think we could sell out the Greek
Theater you are cool with the 50% fee I
didn't hear that no I'm not no we're not
cool with that but by the way all the
box office go goes to them so talk to
them amazing congrats finally he does
something good for you guys and all your
hard work thank you so so so you can
pitch that to them I'm not invol you
guys we can move the room caps up a lot
right so you think you don't need to
technically sell it out it's a podcast
you think embarrassing no you want to
sell it up that's amazing amazing maybe
that's cool no no don't say
that um wow that's amazing thank you
guys yeah I think you could have done
something bigger but the hard part is
there's not a lot of options so you can
move up obviously there's the 4,000 the
plaum 5,000 for the shrine that's kind
of the ballpark and then it moves up to
like the floor in the Kia Forum you can
do just the floor that's like 7,000 The
Forum that's where we saw we saw you too
there and then you could do like the
full Kia Forum which is like something
like
16,700 I think it's 17500 Ace family
sold out Staple Center they sure did bro
if 16,000 fuba tro showed up in one
place I don't think it' be they have at
Oliver Tree Festival right so you might
the world is not ready for that many
poopa Troopers well we are we are
already planning for the Greek uh next
summer which is like 6,000 or so you
guys should have done the Greek for this
one is it too late to change venues well
the Greek is not uh available during the
winter winter it doesn't sound like
people are having a problem that is
winter because it's outdoors though it's
awesome that you sold it out that fast
it sounds like you guys are doing it
nice and right and um you could have
done bigger but it's cool that you have
that demand I feel frankly that I'm
insecure that if it didn't sell out like
this is what I imagine you get
discouraged if it didn't s like if we
put it up and then let's say okay the
members got everything they wanted and
then it goes to the non-members and then
it's like there's still like a few
thousand left now that's a sizable crowd
but I feel that that you know it would
hurt my feelings and so I'm scared of
that okay well and so but that that is
amazing thank you guys for um for the
support that's nuts thank you guys so
much that's crazy I feel like it sold
out faster than the last time
somehow uh maybe it's about the same I
think it was about the sameish I don't
understand that though it doesn't the
numbers are not make sense bro listen
there's a more incentive this time too
because the last couple live shows that
we've done we just kind of had it as
generic live show people know they're
coming to the steaming that's a big deal
the hottest it's the hottest it's
YouTube's H it night of the year I mean
they're going to get a zoom call from
alliv our I'm going to zoom in and
promote my ALB
yeah um wow I'm just I'm just basking in
the glory for a minute here uh thank you
to everybody that's
amazing I feel like we failed because we
didn't crash the website this time do
that happened last time last two times
yeah but we did Ticket Master are we
going to crash Ticket Master we can do
it if we Taylor Swift wasn't it t or it
was AXS last time or something I don't
know yeah you know what I mean I'm not
Taylor Swift cam so how do we do this
same model but with my festivals my
shows how do we get your fans to get
over there the first objective if I were
you is to make good music right well
that's out of the question I'm kidding
let's keep it serious up Ethan you don't
like my music I get it no I do I
genuinely did love your new album let's
talk about Oliver now thank you
everybody I'm I'm just basking in the
glory this is amazing thank you guys you
guys both congrats to the whole team I
wish you guys the best I'm we're going
to put on Amazing show so much F will be
there in person thank you everyone would
you go you know have you seen these um
these Contraptions in the stage where it
shoots them up oh yeah I love those you
do those no I have a bad L1 L2 problems
so I can't do it sciatica would you do
that at our show I would love
to what if you were in a wheelchair or
something and then we shoot you out in
the wheelchair that awes I would I did a
whole tour in a wheelchair one time I
got I lost onethird of the blood in my
body and I damaged my foot and I had to
do the whole T in a wheelchair and I had
a microphone on I do wheelie spins
around that's how bad I really wanted to
make it work mhm it was crazy it was one
of those things I like I don't know if I
ever told you the story not to get too
graphic but I was going to the first
show and I had an ulcer that erupted
right before the flight and I was
projectile vomiting blood on the
airplane and they turned it around and
they were like there's an ambulance here
waiting for you they're like do you want
to take this there's three options you
take the ambulance the second option is
you cancel your flight and you can come
back tomorrow if you go to doctor's not
or the third option you can get the next
flight I was like this is an interesting
option between the second and third and
I told them that's how badly you have to
feel like you have to show up and I
literally just said I'll get the next
flight so you did actually do a show in
a wheelchair did aour again I don't know
what you're talking about goodbye
farewell tour and then is this your last
tour this will be the official last tour
why is that
funny you've had a few of finals well
the thing is you never know but yeah
this is very much going to be my last
tour this is it last chance to see
Oliver tree yeah it was crazy so you did
it in a wheelchair the whole tour yeah I
mean I was going to either cancel it or
do it in a wheelchairs those are the
options now can I ask you this question
do you could now like a little ableist
perhaps what to go out there in a
wheelchair my foot was completely I I
had a full-on break in the bottom part
and I wasn't able to walk really yeah I
had a whole I had to wear a cast on it
well okay and then you said what was the
other blood thing can we corroborate
that I lost one/ third of the blood in
my body due to the ulcer yeah and um and
I couldn't breathe so did this I played
a bunch of shows like the first few ones
and it got progressively worse and by
the time I did a special guest slot at
Red Rocks I was like is this the
tivation I couldn't breathe I thought my
grand father died from empyema I thought
maybe it could be asthma or empyema but
I couldn't breathe and what happens is
when you lose that much blood is that
there's not enough blood getting to your
lungs so your lung capacity your
breathing capacity goes down and so I
couldn't breathe and I got super scared
and and I started doing testing and
different things and they like you're
anemic you've lost onethird of the blood
in your body and I started taking like
blood supplement pills and then I had
you you lost it all from from projectile
vomiting it was blood it was number two
and I had I was diarrhe blood and
throwing it up that's that's super scary
it a very scary situation and you were
still going to go out and do the show
that's how much that you feel the
pressure If you cancel a show people
like hate you so upset with you and it's
out of the artist control and they're
the ones who have villainized from it
and it's such such a bummer that's how
much pressure I felt the time that I was
like I can't cancel this so were you
able to treat the ulcer yeah I it was
something that took a long time I mean
they had to do the indin oscopy and the
colonoscopy at the they did the double
double bro I was I was I always imagine
the double where the cameras go high
five in the middle MH they meet your
large intestines valve and really
hardcore though it was pretty scary time
for me cuz you're like what's wrong with
me what is going on that's not a normal
thing so how did that happen that sounds
really scary it happened from
basically I was taking unprescribed IB
it was like doctor level Tylenol or
Ibuprofen Tylenol yeah and I also had a
predisposition because I had some dis I
had eaten from another overseas that I
had like my stomach was at
predisposed disposition where that would
happen very likely so I got rid of that
other issue that I had as well by taking
medicine that created an open space for
olers to be more invited and then I
damaged my foot it went through
different phases and I was taking all
this ipren from my dad he's like oh you
could take this as B is like five times
as strong Tylen it's called Uh I know
moin whatever it was it was super
hardcore on your stomach and like it
fried my stuff ibuprofen super dangerous
people don't people don't
understand I I I've seen doctors saying
like if that was invented today it would
1,000% not be over the counter cuz it's
it can really your organs and and
um here let's chat gbt let's ask the
expert no I I've heard that I and I've
heard I've heard I don't take it unless
it's like an emergency type situation
wow God I take Tylenol I think tyl I
have a headache right now and I was like
you want Tylenol no I don't want to take
anything you're scared to take I don't
take it I try not to take things unless
it's a more emergency cuz Tylenol as I
is pretty more mild these things are all
hard on your liver and I am sober so I
try not to take anything but I do take
melatonin and I drink coffee you take
melatonin to sleep yeah I mean I
sometimes I didn't take it last night
but I do what milligram is you take well
dude I just got a package cuz a lot of
times it's legal and overseas like you
can't get it in England really yeah wow
it's crazy I don't that hit at Walmart M
yeah but I got 60 Mig for the tour what
but I don't know I I have to sleep on
airplanes cuz I have to reset my time
schedule 60 Mig yeah I've never I never
got ones that big I didn't even know
they sold it but I usually take a couple
10 I sometimes I have it by my bed when
I need it it's like a 5 milligram and
that knocks me out 60 60 but here's the
thing I've learned since I travel so
much I don't have the option to be able
to have jet lag right so there's ways
around jet lag and if you sleep sleep on
the plane so whatever the time is let's
say it's 400 p.m. I just either stay
awake till I get on the right sleep
schedule or I go to bed at some weird
hour like like in the middle of the day
I'll just try to take sleeping aid but I
try to take actual hardcore sleeping
medicine because that stuff's just as
bad you know anything that's real
interesting cuz that that's an issue I
imagine a lot of artist traveling artist
touring I've always wondered about that
you can avoid the jet log if you set
your biological clock on the flight over
so I found it works well so you find
that
you don't feel jet lag so much anymore I
don't really get it no that's good I
actually don't experience it do you just
try to stay on yeah you can't so you try
to reset but you're going in so many
different time zones it's crazy it seems
so hard to get on top of that your body
acclimates it gets used to that does
touring like is it really difficult
because of all the traveling um I don't
know yeah the part that's hard about it
is that pretty much none of it is the
shows it's mostly the traveling the
hotels the airports uh um so it's it's a
lot it's really I guess there's this
famous quote about it where it's like
they pay us to travel we play the shows
for free that's kind of the idea it's
like the shows are amazing there's times
where I got to a show and it's like
raining like thunder lightning and they
cancel I'm like we already got here we
already unloaded my big cow out of the
semi Tru and I'm like I wish I could
just play you know they're going to pay
you from this thing is force majour they
do this thing where it's in the contract
where if there's out of you know it's
out of your hands and it's like uh
natural disaster that you still get paid
your full amount but you're like well we
already came out this way I'd rather
play the show than sit in a hotel room
it'd be way more fun right so by the way
I got a Chachi pulled up a real good one
so number one side effect of ibuprofen
and this is what happened to you is it
can irritate the stomach lemming and
cause Gast gastritis ulcers and bleeding
it's crazy taking AB with food or milk
can help reduce the risk second one is
cardiovascular risk some studies say
that taking ibuprofen can be associated
with with increased risk of heart attack
or stroke oh my God this is this drug is
dangerous pretty much every drug
is dangerous though you know right but
this one is very dangerous can we say
that we could say that thank you kidney
damage liver damage allergic reactions
blood pressure blood
clotting it has a ton of drug
interactions that's why I'm on anti so I
can't take it because it it has a
negative interaction with with with so I
can only take Tylenol so if you look
this up about tyo it would be less
severe than all this I think so here
let's see how let me let me rephrase
this question for you uh chat my boy GPT
in the house how
dangerous is IU Pro fin verse Tylenol
gp's
out yeah so I'm sorry that happened man
you got got by the big by big uh big
farma yeah I mean it's just part of the
journey you know I've had so many things
I've broken like eight bones before I
mean little bleeding out it's not the
worst thing that ever happened to me a
little bleeding out so let's see both
Ibuprofen and Tylenol are commonly used
I know that so here it's listing all the
terrible things about ibuprofen so
Tylenol says or sorry yeah Tylenol says
the most significant risk with Tylenol
is liver damage or failure that sounds
pretty bad especially when taken in high
dose or combined with alcohol so you
kind of got to around overdosing
time I mean that's jeez yeah there isn't
though it's just liver damage and high
doses with alcohol overd only liver
damage but you with high doses with
alcohol yeah but without alcohol if you
do high doses it's hard on your liver no
matter what right alol you shouldn't
just take them that's make it even worse
but it's still hard especially if you
take a lot but it says uh allergic
reactions are rare but possible uh skin
reactions you can get a rash you don't
you can't drink alcohol with it that's
it you know what I mean I'm I'm a
Tylenol
boy I'm happy thanks bro I got some So
what at what point are we going to start
the
episode Oh I thought we were didn't you
want to do like a casual what kind of
question I thought it would be more like
an interview what kind of questions did
you want me to answer do you want me to
give you
questions no just tell me like what was
favorite color favorite food what's your
favorite color I don't have fun ID no
but I will say this on on the discussion
of the live show MH I I do want to share
first of all that is crazy that
you guys sold that ticket that's no
small feat um and I've been working on
my life show like the one you looked at
the picture of me in the wheelchair that
was like five six years ago I am so
excited and I hope you guys get the
chance to see this concert I know that
stars haven't aligned in the past are
you coming to La we might
be I can't say okay but we're going to
be there or San Diego anywhere we're
going to this is I want right now we're
going across Australia 16 countries
through Europe I'm doing Bali Indonesia
next week seriously Indo yeah playing a
pool party the biggest Club in indes is
like is it you have Indonesian fans or
is it like a tourist spot there's fans
everywhere that's the thing about Tik
Tok and yeah right honestly Indonesia
was like some of the first audiences to
adapt life goes on like random overseas
audiences are the ones who make it go
often so wow so wow that's super but the
show I'm so excited for you to see
because I've spent literally millions of
dollars making this can you tell us a
little bit about the setup of the show
yeah so the thing that makes it
different from all the other concerts
that I've ever seen or ever put on is I
wrote a 35 page screenplay for this
concert so it's a mixture of a movie a
TV show a play a concert you have
standup comedy you have motivational
speaking you have WWE wrestling and of
course scooter stun so it's 36 the
entertainment the cool thing is all the
music videos that I've invested Millions
upon millions of dollars making are all
part of this and they're all part of one
feature film essentially going to play
them your music videos no it connects
all the dots I filmed all the gaps of
how they all tie together so you get to
see it as one experience it's like a
video art would you say um yeah I mean
it's a it's like the thing is while
these videos are playing too I'm in the
outfit of each music video I have these
things called slates in my ear where
it's saying move left move right while
I'm singing I have take a bite from the
sandwich do these certain things so
everything is like it's like a live
Broadway musical mixed in with the
concert with the movie sounds hold on
you have a slate in your ear telling you
to move left so I'm singing the song
right I can hear the songs I have these
things called in years but then I'm
basically going like this while I'm
singing I know the song so I'm like
singing it and then it says move left
one two three move up my whole body
movements are choreographed with the
movement one two three go so while I'm
singing I'm like going through all these
different motions in my head yo you guys
he's going to be synchronized y'all
better see this show right now but no
it's really epic cuz I really was you
know I have the dream to focus on film
making so that's why I'm so into making
music videos and build my own production
company and yada yada but you know at a
certain point I'm like okay I want to
make these feature films I wrote four
feature film ideas but it's hard when
you start something you spend so much
time building something it's like like
imagine if you started Teddy fresh and
you start getting it going and then
you're like you know I think I want to
actually switch over and get into
Pottery like I put so much work in my
life's working this thing so I'm like I
found a way to still focus in on being a
filmmaker and director and make a movie
that I can play as a live show so it's
it's something that satisfies you merge
all your dreams into one like 360
everything I could want and then it's
like something truly unique I feel like
it's hard to reinvent the wheel you're
never going to do it but in this context
I've made something very special and I
feel like it's it's very much something
that is almost made for like this ADHD
generation so there's so much stuff
happening that you can
kind of latch on the things you like if
you don't want to watch the visuals at
all there's a full band playing will
there be um Subway Surfer playing on the
screen Subway Surfer I'm not familiar
kinetic sand or kinetic sand cutting or
anything like that none of that no but
that might be in the next version well
I'm just saying if you maybe if we if
you want something for everyone we did
have you never seen Subway Surfer can
you pull it up cuz we're probably going
to need it for this interview if it
keeps like this we are going to need
something can we just trim the first
half when it goes up I mean it's live
it's already live it's not really trim
said this was going to be live I didn't
get that approval let's let's start it
over um I wanted to ask you this you
said like how much pressure you have
right to go out and do a show has there
been times when you had to cancel the
show yeah and a lot of it is out of my
control whether it's a health thing
that's that's one thing and I still
always try to play no matter how sick I
get no matter how bad things get the
other thing is like the agents the
certain things there's things tied to it
that have nothing to do with the artist
and then you're the villain because
people's you know are worked so hard to
get these tickets just something where
for example I can't give uh specific
examples about something very current
situation but it's like that market is
completely dead and everyone selling
tickets there is dead and I have no
choice but like the people who I work
with they're like well it's not your
fault so we're going to pay you anyways
for these shows but it's not oh wow yeah
so it's like that crazy where it's out
of my control that's crazy they still
pay you yeah I know but it's it's that
much out of the artist's hands that
they're not even involved they have no
decision them wow so it's like like a
force majour it's like okay you get
there but it rains so we pay you who
pays you the the it's not your fault
well I've done a deal with Live Nation
Oh So Live Nation covers it they can
afford they help like make it all work
okay let keep it positive I can't say
that they're scumbags well what if I
said Teddy fresh was run by a bunch of
scumbags but right that'd be probably I
wouldn't of course you but Live Nation
isn't that like you do I don't know
they're like monster company that's like
saying Bill Gates is a scumbag is why
would you say that about him right I'm
just using an
example have you heard about what he's
doing with our potatoes no it's crazy I
can't get into it right now cuz I can't
talk about it on so here's the thing
going back concer not to drive this into
the ground but I think what we need to
do is open up the floodgates uh can we
get a countdown from mine what I was
going to ask you is was there ever a
time you had to cancel that was because
you were sick or something like I'm just
curious okay so for example I was
supposed to play in San Diego I was
throwing my Festival fire Fest yeah
where I had Smashmouth opening up for me
and I had put together rest in peace I
know RI to the goat mhm that's never
going to happen again man um maybe wait
so what happened so I this year I had to
get surgery on my voice I couldn't talk
for five weeks I couldn't sing for 3
months but before that I basically went
to the doctor and he said I had a whole
tour plan and he's like if you do these
shows in the next next few days you're
going to have to cancel the entirety of
the show so you need to go on no talking
vocal rest wow and just and they looked
into my throat I it was something that
was the hardest decision cuz I'm like
this is my dream Festival smash this the
band I literally grew up listening to
and like if you're lucky he might even
do a h Hitler on stage all right we're
going to stop you right there he did do
that right he did do that let's not
speak ill of the Dead oh good
point he did though yeah he did that sh
by the way Diane Feinstein right
found it I can't endorse any of this
stuff you're say I don't even know what
you're talking about it's better for you
to just pretend like you don't know
actually Ethan unfortunately I saw an
announcement earlier that um despite her
death uh she's going to be rerunning she
still running
yeah God she does not she just she she's
on that grind she's alltime Hustler I
was on Twitter and I saw everyone doing
these super heartfelt tributes and I was
like man that dude and I I just put
out a tweet where I just said her I
was just like she sucks dude she's 90
years old dude
90 I don't know if you follow this stuff
follow I don't use the internet so I'm
pretty I don't know who these people are
or any of what you're talking about I
didn't even hear about the submarine
thing until a couple weeks ago the
submarine that's an ancient meme at this
point that's how out of the game I am
wow you must have been captivated by
that though I was like what's going on I
must know more yeah I can tell you I'm a
pro on the topic do you know everything
about it I heard enough I think I have
the gist of it just it's wild is yeah
PlayStation Two controller mhm yeah
crazy I can't believe a driv in that
thing with that but yeah I was out of
the loop I missed a lot of stuff look
I'm I'm even getting these Dan uh the
worst person you know made a point you
agree with is that a picture of Dan it's
a bipartisan uh yeah right that's a not
a picture of Dan
no I'm not going to read it though have
you heard about lizy in the box like who
lizy in the box I have no idea what oh
the queen she
died who's Lizzy in the Box
Queen the Queen Elizabeth yeah Queen
Elizabeth I've heard of her have you
heard of England have you heard of the F
say that I'm playing you're playing
shows in England are you London you
might want to say when you get like
losing in the box is that a thing I
don't know what that is actually I'm
curious if you were playing a show in UK
and he said Lizzy in a box would people
be happy or would it be funny I don't
know I don't know I I I'm genuinely
people would be a little some people
would be mad this is Queen Elizabeth you
don't recognize her I'm
familiar she got fat she got badass
hats her hat game's crazy Princess Diana
you know about him her heard of her you
know and she's
dead she's in a
box which is where we all go right my
dog passed away I know I'm so sorry to
hear that thank you when's the tattoo
tomorrow and um what's the plan you're
taking some kind of drug so you don't
feel it no I'm not going to do that not
happening anymore I talked to a real
tattoo artist and he's like this is how
we should do it I'm going to come to
your house so that I can focus and I'm
not going to be you know distracted and
I don't think you should take
painkillers either because apparently it
can warp the skin or make the tattoo
come out differently right and look at
yourself too like especially your face
it is pretty warped already to begin
right you wouldn't want to do even more
warping but is it just a permanent thing
or do you know what a tattoo is it's a
real tattoo I don't have any so no you
have any either of you no it's my first
one wow I'm actually off to you thanks
I'm actually really excited
because you know it's been so hard and I
think it will it will comfort me to have
him be so close all the time I'm happy
for you I think that's amazing idea
you're H but you're not happy that my
dog died of course not cuz if we worded
that in a way that I just make sure
what's on the screen here who the
is that
oh what is going on dude are you I'm
trying to keep Good Vibes here and I'm
getting a lot of lashback a lot of
negative Vibes I don't think we I don't
think this has anything to do with us
what is going on how much did you pay
this
guy is this your trainer isn't this your
boxing
trainer no we don't and we don't pay him
I don't know what the deal is
like does he
speak um not
lately so I'm trying to figure out
what's going on here Ethan I'm trying to
have a positive interaction with you for
the first time ever I'm trying to go
along with the show and just be a guy
who who's sitting in here but I'm
getting a lot of this negative kind of
energy yeah turn that
off thank you so anyway uh we were
talking about um the album the album so
did you actually listen to it I sent it
to you guys you're the first people who
I ever sent it to what did you think I I
genuinely thought it was really fun
what's your first song it's really fun I
liked the the first one was really good
and I also liked and I'm going to tell
you for real cuz we can hear this music
you green L us right yes so bounce was
good that was the one
that I really liked and then the other
one I really liked I mean they're all
nice but the do you know there's a new
music video that came out today ugly
ugly side I like I produced that by
myself no one helped without that was
that one was really good so there you go
I did listen to it thank you
appreciate it which one what music video
came out today uh with you I'm actually
so so very proud of it and I think it's
going to be the last large scale music
video that I ever release at this point
in time music videos are just massive
waste of money I think the era of the
music video is yeah of course no I agree
I spent millions of dollars making these
videos in Serbia I live I lived there
three months I was just locked in making
it and here we are no one's even
watching this I mean 8 million is pretty
good no not really it's not not in
comparison to millions of dollars compar
compared the series this a three-part
Trilogy which was released out of order
but the third one came out today let me
ask I agree with you in general I think
music videos are well if I post the
clips on Tik Tok no one is just like so
no one wants that over L produced stuff
they want some raw cell phone food yeah
it seems like such an outlet For You
video so I wonder how how you're going
to Pivot instead of making that stuff I
mean this there's a lot of conversations
about this being the last Oliver tree
album really the last tour the last
album yeah that's how I see it I feel
like I've gotten my my message out there
this is Oliver tree when he announces
his last tour
[Applause]
[Laughter]
look he looks good Hees he does look
good
um let me I have a question about this
song yeah well you're not going to claim
us right I know you're tight on cash
that's what you've been telling us no I
don't make any money off any of this
stuff the label does we'll clear you you
better clear me cuz this my
job you know what I
mean what were you going to ask about it
I'll I'll I have a question about this
music video yeah what's up are you
paying residuals to effects twins to who
to effects twins for uh ripping off
their music video effect twins effect
twins I'm not familiar did you rip off
the effect
twins I don't know what does that mean I
just see a little similarity to
something I've seen before wait what's
happening pull it up I'm not we're not
cleared on that one well we we'll just
mute
it all right let's uh any other
questions we don't we don't have to get
into
it no doubt baby please don't make a son
you're waking on my neighbors now
that's a beautiful build right there it
is I think it's like you
know 100 grand for a build that's in the
video for like maybe 40 seconds 30
seconds probably less if you want it to
look real good like that well the other
side of it you can see how big it is
too look long it goes that's a green
screen is it no that's a real built
screen bro do you know how much this set
I mean there's am I crazy or is that a
green screen that is not a green screen
I can guar this shot is in front of a
green screen that is not in front of a
green screen this one okay hold on let
me let me this is not a green screen so
the chair let me I'm confused about
everything
now why would you build the set because
I'm making a video everything's
built there's definitely a carpet and a
chair but this is this is digital right
there no that's not digital this is a
build uh nowadays it's kind of hard to
tell does kind of look like a set
extension but I I feel like I directed
it I wrote the video I produced it I
think I would know if it's real I'll
take his word for it the xterior is a
separate set so this is one that we we
had a roof that was built cuz I couldn't
it's not like a real limousine I didn't
build the actual car it's an interior
did you pay all these weirdos yeah and
there's a couple fans that came actually
how much do you pay someone to just
stand there with their hands up I don't
know I'm not in D with the payment of
each individual extra oh you don't know
how much do you pay your your hard work
well you said oh I did everything so I
asked you one simple question do that he
produced it Ean okay you produced
there's I'm executive producer I don't
deal with paid actors though and you but
you shot this in Serbia I don't think
people make money there people make
money there sorry should I button that
no I you're just going to get cancelled
I hear what you said so I said I just
said I don't think that well that's why
Oliver went to sery so you didn't have
to pay them that's not why I went to
Serbia I went there for the buildings if
you look at the new video I just dropped
you could see why I went to Serbia he
said last time that he loves the
architecture the brutalist architecture
sure you have to see it there is arure
there he's not lying I mean look at the
last shot of the new video it's my
favorite shot I've ever filmed for
anything ever okay hold on hold on hold
on I have a question about this the
lyrics look at the buildings there
they're crazy reminds me Isel what
that's like a dime a dozen project
looking building
you you've seen it
all I mean am I crazy that just looks
like any kind of low in a interesting
texture you can't even see the scope of
it if you look at it in other shots it's
actually a stair building so the whole
thing is stair for real this is just a
small insert of it but it basically is
like steps down like a staircase and
then when you need to get permits to
shoot something like this do you grease
the wheels or is there official ways to
do you have to get permits for all this
stuff yeah you get permits did anyone
you get shook down or or anything I
don't know anything about Serbia no no
safe place honestly loved it I got to
live there 3 months I spent time there
before I I played a show there and I
just looked around and saw the buildings
and I said when it came up to the
conversation of the next music videos I
was to shoot they're like where do you
want to do it and I was my whole life is
center around I have to do X Y and Z
things I have to go film videos I have
to go finish the album but it doesn't
say where so I take advantage of the the
opportunity to go live somewhere else
get inspiration cuz I go and burn myself
out so hardcore that I found in helps me
feel inspired while I'm going so intense
like the filming of this stuff was it
took everything out of me it took every
bit of my heart and definitely do seem
like uh but yeah this is not a practical
Thing music videos at this scale doesn't
make sense anymore but if you look at
the last shot of the last video I will I
will I'll look at everything I'm so
proud of it and that's why you can see
oh this is why this guy went to Serbia
there's nothing like it anywhere else in
the world I I'm pretty sure that uh oh
we're going to watch everything I
promise I'mma bounce you up and down you
what does that mean I'm going to bounce
you up and
down what does that
mean what' you say you say I'm going to
bounce you up and down what does that
mean what do you think Ethan you're a
mature guy I'm asking you what does it
mean what do you
think I don't know like a ball like a
bouncy ball it's about a basketball B A
basketball it's a song about sex I never
made a song about sex before this is the
first time you're going to bounce you're
going to bounce them up and down you
dog if you play your cards right Ethan
kids listen to this music let's go dude
dude hey well it's a sexual inuendo I
don't say anything directly I'm going to
bounce you could you could take it and
it could be whatever about whatever you
think if you're a basketball player
Dan Dan is saying that this is inspired
by I've never seen that shot in my life
oh the difference is this is
funnier wait I don't he didn't have a
shot like this did he I don't remember I
didn't see something like that wait wait
is this real yeah this is the music
video for the song Oh that's sick that's
such a funny
idea wait hold on let me go back I don't
remember look at this shot really quick
this is the this don't you think there's
a way for you to produce like there's
got to be a middle ground you can
produce these without spending so much
money but still have a yeah the tech get
there which it seems like it is starting
to get there with AI yeah maybe I don't
need to go so far and spend so much time
and this shot right here is like 20
different layers let me crowd is
actually five different or there's six
layers for just the people with the
cameras you got the car driving that's
one layer you got the Civ building
behind that's another layer each of
those buildings and then those Towers on
top those are different layers the sky's
a different layer you're saying stair
five different things this is like 12
different things composited together
look at the staircase the the red carpet
that was actually two pieces of thing we
we connected it through bfx it's so much
time and effort in so did you guys all
shoot this in the same location no it's
a bunch of different locations oh
wow but oh I see this part yeah the idea
is obviously I was so inspired by aex
twin my whole life I was on a record
label that he was on and so I love aex
Twi oh that's cool but I thought you
said effect twins which I didn't know
what you were referring to oh sorry I
know the Apex twins no not apex apex or
he one of the Godfathers of experiment
Al electronic music so he's but it's
about not stealing an idea but building
upon an idea so if you look
at mine is like you know quite an
elaborate setup I just I'm also a fan I
I got the reference and I just wanted to
you know the thing is every you're never
going to recreate the wheel and it's
important to understand with art it's
about taking an idea and expanding upon
it because whether you know you've
thought of it or not like here's the
thing Dan about this shot you say Apex
Twin came up with it but you know what
it's really from what is it from The
Mask they have multiple shots as a
shitty version
but they have Lio d one sh where it D so
I already know that they didn't invent
this shot they just did it and the
people who did the VFX of that shot mhm
they were the mentor of my friend who
did the VFX or the person who did it for
Apex Twin for that video he was the
mentor of the person who did it for this
video so there's actually a lineage wow
that's cool it's a respect for the
lineage of the Artistry well that's
fantastic but go to the shot of the
where you were at with the the crowds
the beginning no no no just when you
where you cut it off it's a little
before this yeah after this yeah go to
this this shot is so wild you can go
after this
yeah I'm so stoked to have the
opportunity actually walk through this
with you cuz I never got to do this with
anyone really the thing is your music
videos are so detailed and crazy that it
actually is really interesting to go
through that with you you are an artist
bro I appreciate that you really truly
are I thank you and it shows in your
music cuz generally you know people who
too focused on the art their music isn't
as good what do you mean by that I don't
know but I appreciate
it but check this out so this shot is so
crazy like the amount of time and work
that went into so you're really crowds
surfing here I'm crowd surfing here but
we we could you know we had budgetary
limitations so you have to composite we
have maybe let's say 50 people so like
that's probably where the crowd starts
to end and then you do like farming but
this shot too I had a crane that was
above me a tech crane that's spinning so
it's real footage mix but look how crazy
that is like that's extremely
psychedelic do you ever wor the BTS that
feel filmed I had two would be fil me
but it's just you know I'm kind of I'm
looking to release these things as
documentaries later I feel like right
now if I released it it's content but
when it comes out five or six years
later then it's more of a historical
time capsule and I think people will
actually appreciate it more I don't know
that's where I'm at my mom just tweeted
this my son Ethan just sold out the
Dolby Theater I'm so
proud thanks Mom
uh appreciate that Mom thank you this
picture by the way this is me as a baby
obviously you are an ugly baby thank you
I don't say that often you're about to
swallow those words because watch this I
showed this to Theodore my precious son
4 years old who you just called ugly
monster I said who do you think this is
and he said it's a picture of me so now
what do you have to say to Theodore it's
a great guy he's a four-year-old child
that you just well how's Michael also I
don't know Michael we don't have a
Michael when I asked Theodore that
wasn't that funny Theodore and Michael
and then you got the new one are you
naming your new kid Oliver no to be
honest we were thinking about it think
about it though what happened the reason
we did it because of you bro come on
Legit why wouldn't you do it you know
that it would be a smart business
decision yeah like you make so much
money from the name
Oliver all right let's go back to where
we from yeah we were being nice uh no
but we're we're going to name the two
the new boy Scotty after our after our
Shredder that was his maiden name I love
it it's a good name strong name thank
you strong choice not as good as Oliver
but not that bad I appreciate that's a
big concession coming from you well as
long as you know the agreement I can be
the Godfather M no we didn't agree to
that well technically we talked about it
so um okay so you have your first song
is about sex which is a little vulgar uh
the next one is one and only
I notic there's a lot of love songs in
this something you want to tell me yeah
if you listen to the story of this album
if you sequentially listen to it through
and not hop around like you did Ethan do
you want me to go back I thought we did
it wear me out how much more do you want
me to analyze that no I want to share
something with you that's to answer your
question so in this modern day and age a
lot of it does start with like a sexual
experience and then that leads to
finding the right person traditionally
speaking people might fall in love first
and have sex later but this is the story
of oh you know okay meeting someone and
then it's becomes a love story and then
it turns into a breakup and then an
isolation away from it all so I see this
is a story it's a narrative driven so
you guys had a so you guys had a mad you
guys like crazy huh it's about
sex I'm not allowed to answer you made
her bounce up and down or something like
that so what is position is that when
you're bouncing up and down reverse
cowgirl okay okay can we not use these
sounds what are you guys doing no we've
we look at this building so so play the
shot right here this is not the building
I was referring to in video 3 this is
video 2 this is a Love Song by the way
familyfriendly this is so you must had
wait what so I'm actually confused this
is like the buildings that are out there
in Ser this is why I chose Serbia like
I've never seen a building that looks
like this with these shapes so hold on
you're being it looks like you're
actually hung over I am actually being
hung over I have wires connected yeah
there got to be crazy but now here when
you zoom out it transitions to
oh I see I see yeah I was super bad this
shot was done horribly by the way but we
ran out of
budget what was that
sound so that shot right there if you
look at
this I designed this outfit I love it
thank you you did that's cool pretty
hard right you're in like a gown it's
like kind of like
a lower budget version of
Batman I feel like that could be Runway
ready totally like not even well I have
a version of it for the runway it's much
longer I'll say that I won't get too
into look at these these things are
incredible too that building behind me I
was driving through seeing all these
vehicles and seeing the buildings and I
was I fell in love
mhm look at these like even just this
Alleyway I'm like I'm just for me it's
very unique looking and so I'm very
inspired by the Eastern block and with
the tensions between in the war between
Russia and Ukraine both the places I've
spent a lot of time at and so I can't go
there right now you know it's not a and
if you had to pick one to win the war
who would which I'm not going to do this
really you can't even say I'm not I'm
anti-political this isn't I'm not on any
side Ukraine has I'm not going to say
anything about I'm about to hit the
button right now youc I'm not going to
say anything I don't know anything about
any of it who's just aggressively taking
Ukraine unprovoked I don't know this is
this is you're me he doesn't even know
about the submarine I didn't even know
about the subar sum learned about it no
tell you the truth I don't know anything
about anything so I'm not the dude to
speak on anything but obviously like it
sounds
horrible I'm not supportive that's all
I'm hearing go ahead not supportive of
in any capacity I don't know about
it I couldn't even have a this is what I
hear when you say that Vladimir you
putting respect on his name Vladimir
Putin Vladimir Putin that's all I I do
not know anything about any of this
dude like I'm not informed I'm not
informed in US politics I don't know
anything about anything you sound like
it sounds horrible and
Vladimir Putin how's that okay the start
that's all I don't know anything okay
now will you say um wait dude we
got to hit this button this is so bad
like this is not what I can't do this
I'm too I can't hit the button it's
been too long I just don't do politics
right right I don't know anything about
any of it right this is not the kind of
conversations I came here to have okay
so what do you want me to ask just just
talk about your music or something I
don't know go ahead this is a bad
episode I'm going to have to walk out
what just go ahead and talk can me and
hila just talk instead sure it's fine um
I'm joking you can keep going but yeah I
don't know man I don't really want to I
don't I I would say yeah obviously you
know support Ukraine but I don't know
anything about any of this so like
you're talking to the wrong guy to be
informed I love like the geographical
locations but I don't do politics so
right right right right I'm not involved
with anything I don't get on any sides
of politics in America a lot people said
about Nazi Germany and it's like oh yeah
I don't know anything about politics
it's like okay all right I'm about to
walk I'm just saying I'm just saying you
know it's like hey you know I don't know
anything I don't know anything I don't
know nothing about nobody how much did
you know about we do say that a lot on
this I do say that a lot I do I say that
like almost every day so you're playing
video games now yeah what is happening
here no go ahead on your left on your
left all right I I'm I think it's time
for me to go just talk talk about your
music you know have you ever been in
Israel no I have not okay because we
have a lot of buildings that look like
that like that
aesthetic like things I think you might
like
it sensitivity is too low on this what
is going on he's playing video games in
the middle I don't know I've never seen
him do that this is uh CS2 it just came
out yesterday sorry taged him taged him
bro we're not doing the podcast
anymore what is this I'm going to AC it
I'm going to H it
what is going on here I'm a hey I'm at a
I'm at a oh you're opening yeah we're in
the same game hey hello oh what the
did I come here for just talk you
wanted to play no I didn't come here so
you could play video games okay hold on
hold on on here I'm no dude hold on hold
on we'll move on to Essence this is the
no Essence isn't part of the series what
you don't want me to listen to
it third one came he's down he's down
well do you don't want to hear me play
it I'll play it for you
all right guys close I want to hear it I
want okay fine fine fine fine fine f
close the game fine it's just it's
counter- strike to it leave you want to
play The Narrative you would go to the
third video that came out today with you
I want to see sorry let me just finish
sorry let me just finish this
round this is this is a red game I just
I a video came out it's a red
game bro just let me finish this round
just no no
no Dam that was sick how dare
you all right I'm I'm my album came out
today I'm out this is what this he
turned it off he he turned it off look
look I his album came out today counter
but Counterstrike 2 came out yesterday
so I mean what which one is more
important people waiting a decade for
Counter Strike to to come out or more 20
years maybe even
dude feel like my whole life serious
interiew talking about Ty all
the whole I be Pro I sit down
I'm done I closed it we're done it's
it's it's good we apologize good
it's good it's good it is
good all right can we see the video that
came out today so that's uh Essence no
with you came out today and I should be
promoting it not being on here while you
play video games okay okay okay so here
let's I do I love you know what I did
yesterday NPR dude you did yes they
treat me a lot differently how many
people listen to that who I don't
know man I was in NBR what uh what host
interviewed Scott yeah Scot Scott just
Scott Scott s he just goes by I don't
know I don't know anything okay you know
what though I want to r m brand head I
want to ref because um I do love NPR I
with ir that's okay so wait with
you this is the new one right yes this
is the third one of the trilogy they
came out of order sequentially because I
ran out of money and I had to put
something good for when the Alum I as
how much did you spend on all this like
what was your I'm not going to get into
the figures but it's in the millions
this is it right right no that one is
just another cheap video I made for dirt
cheap what this is with you isn't it no
that's fair witha the friends huh with
you what's
happening this is this is the With You
music video no that's fair with their
friends don't play it it's not part of
the series so which one should I it's
called with you which one
five okay five fair weather friends
maybe we got it mixed up here my bad my
my bad here is is it this
one yes so this is why I went to Serbia
okay so if you watch the last shot
specifically but this gives you a little
taste of it okay so here is
um um with you it just came out today
came out a few hours
ago you're not going to find that
building somewhere
[Music]
else
I am rectangular what is playing feel it
in my why the
youing what is the what is your
major
malfunction what is your major Mal
function what's the problem bro
I'm this is good
this wait I love the Gown outfit too I
love it let's watch the music video I
just want to watch the music video you
don't like the song look at the look at
the lights sick Bro I'm taking in the
sights and sounds of the music wood
panel walls too don't play this
[Music]
song that's blood from the roof is the
blood a reference to what happened to
you with the uler with the
ulcer did that happen recently the
ulcer why are you why are you a little
person what does that mean is that more
ableism okay I thought I was just
improving it cuz I like the video but I
thought that rectangular was better I
was trying to do you a favor all right
dude I'll play the original one
listen in order for us to talk we would
need a therapist we would need
someone to actually moderate because
whatever is going on here this is not
working
MH well then you should probably go do
the show at the inside the actor Studio
or some because that this is the H3
podcast okay I'm the moderator I'm the
God of this building if I was to bring a
moderator on would you be open to that
so we could have a civil
conversation I mean if it's going to I
guess if it'll keep you from like
complaining either I leave or I bring in
a moderator like right now because we're
live yes you have a why is this
live I didn't agree to do a live episode
BR it's always live been yeah can we
bring in the
moderator sure who is this is this him
Hi how are good I'm actually not too
good but I'm trying to be polite here
you know each other no we do not know
each other you just gave him a hug well
I give everybody hugs no no no you said
hi Oliver how are you if you're going to
be hi Ethan how are you well if you're
going to be an impartial mediator I need
to know that I've never met him I'm not
Fam I'm familiar with you guys I love
the podcast oh thank love you know the
positivity I love it look at all it the
lights I love it okay Oliver reached out
to me okay I could tell he was hurting I
could tell that and then I listened to
his the brand new album alone in the
crowd magnificent by the way you guys do
know each other no we don't just listen
to it after he reached out to me Ethan
please can you not interarch of course
and I could tell it was coming from a
place of pain in his heart that album it
was truly it's a hurting arest it's a
cry for help and then he he literally
did Cry for Help he called me and here
we are today he said that he cries for
help but nobody hears his cries now that
is just I hear your cries Oliver I just
don't understand how it got to this
point these beef sticks back there why
is he eating beef sticks Oliver we have
that I have nothing to do with any you
pulled another beef stick you probably
don't have any more now but you do are
they kosher I don't so just what's with
this guy he's eting our beef it doesn't
matter bro can I speak for a second can
you please not interrupt Oliver I'd
with a beef stick pay attention to me
this is how he operates this show there
you go there you go Ean do we really
have you don't listen I can't even
talk here I can see what you're
talking this is what happens every time
I come on this shitty show this is why I
stopped coming but he just said the show
is shitty that's not okay now Oliver
that's not very nice either is it
clearly he doesn't think the issue is
this coming back I come on here and what
does he do right he just wants to talk
about Tylenol and promote his live show
which is obviously
awesome I truly believe so M why do you
you know what we need to get back
to what where did my picture go we need
to get back to
this what happened to this oh oh wow
here let me adjust that's the drawing
that your sister made now come on look
at a happy family but that was like on
our wall you took it off the wall yes I
take a lot of things off a lot of
people's walls okay took our beef jerky
stick not jerky all right he he brings
up a good point here there was once upon
a time where we were actually friends
and that was actually when we didn't
know each
other that was the closest we ever were
to being friends and I just want to say
so what do we do go do like a well I
don't know I'm not I'm not a
professional therapist like bang our
heads until a few exercises i' like to
try if you're open to it Ethan okay yeah
could we do this oliv them I guess
doctor okay don't touch the don't touch
the art please
that's an expensive piece you guys don't
even have a frame on you have you have
greasy ass beef that's how he gave it to
us beef jerky fingers excuse me falling
apart you guys didn't take good care of
it okay so first one's going to be a
breathing exercise if I could get you
two sitting next to each other can we do
that please I'm not sitting near him
this is not going to go well I can move
over please Ethan would you be open to
it please you promise not to touch me
you don't have to go anyway I'm not
going to move I'm not going to move here
you go I'm not moving what the this
guy how many beef sticks do this guy got
so hey I'm not going anywhere you got to
come here no come on Oliver you told me
you were going to be open Ethan we're
trying to I'm not moving this
the way you treat me I'm trying
to have a serious interview and you
start playing video games I if
you go over there I'll give you a beef
stick more beef sticks my dude this guy
is flush with beef sticks get over
thereo he's good this is already working
out so well this guy is good wait I'm
going to eat this let the record show I
do not want to be here okay what I would
like you guys to do I want to be sitting
over there and I wanted you to come to
me Oliver please what I'd like you guys
to do is Oliver you breathe out and
Ethan you're going to breathe that air
in no way that's disgusting and then
vice versa that's v no no have
the beef stick after they eat beef stick
that's disgusting why do I have to
breathe it in that's gross it's an
energy uh exchange going bring my breath
afterwards of course and then you go out
and then all of you go in can we do this
energy ritual thing is important it's an
energy exchange you travel a lot you get
all kinds of weird don't don't
bring that up okay Doctor that's a real
consideration why do you have so many
beef sticks all right what's the what's
the thing cuz I want you breathe out and
Ethan you breathe in and then Ethan you
breathe out and Oliva you take that back
in get close and what okay all right
count us down good ready and three it's
disgusting two so gross
one now Ethan breathe in oh dude what
the I can't do it stop dude no no
no no no no okay okay okay okay now go
ahead now the opposite okay dude you're
spitting on me stop closer Oliver closer
please Ethan and Oliver please closer
wait seriously seriously you're you're
misting on me
bro you're missing on my beef stick on
that beef breath this is beautiful I
don't think this is working here here
you want to try on I need I need a spit
screen so we'll do it like this well
that's not going to you're going to miss
all the
air you know how a air travel well i'
you you just poke my eyes bro that's
didn't poke your eyes you did a double
poke hard we be say about violence you
double poked my eyes play it back I
didn't do anything wasn't that was good
wasn't good for no it wasn't good for
Oliver that's very bad I didn't do that
poke my I breathe heavy a chance to do
this that's up what do you think
is it three stooges well you guys do
kind of look like well and yeah kind of
Larry when you try to think idiot okay
come on we're going back here why do
have to be like this I didn't poke him
in the eyes I didn't do anything Oliver
yes I saw it you poke him in the what
you poked them in the eyes bull
Oliver I'm not breathing
bring it down come on what the let's
bring it down a not he didn't even
finish this one I'm working on it finish
your first beef stick all right well if
that's not going to work maybe we can
you've all heard the expression walk a
mile on each other's shoes right no
right everybody right we got a round of
applause never heard it
right what are we applauding maybe we
try I don't know what the are we
applauding at my at my practice
therapitas I like to take it one step
further what is it therap I'm Peta the
therapist it's
therapitas okay no Peta you said
therapists that are pedos therapitas
therap.net I have nothing what the this
is like the 10 beef stick um so I like
to take walking and mile each other's
shoes one step further okay and I want
to do a full I'm not going to walk in
your shoes I'll tell you that
pedo you said that not
me see this is what I deal with why did
you invite me here Oliver I invited you
here to try to make things civil in case
things got bad which I knew they would
and obviously you're friends with this
guy no I'm not I brought in a
professional because I knew that if
there was going to have one moment that
went down it was going to all crumble
and it it fell fast tell them how you
really feel Oliva coming on this show
anymore we're going down a good path
here come on reach deeper you really
want to go down this path no I don't you
canceled the show like six
times now do the math let's work on that
who you got bumped you said they bumped
you they bumped me for who was the logic
so the what's his name how manell could
come on or was it Carrot Top I can't
remember it was um the peanut butter
guy is anyone I could find
walking past the office on the
street do the
math look what's the idea because I
don't think your ideas are going to work
there's nothing that can get through his
thick ass head I want you to not
only switch shoes I want you to switch
outfits completely I'm not doing that I
think
Oliver one more for you what if you do
this you'll that's two for you I've
already had two beef sticks Ethan one
more more for you oh my God man if you
guys dude this man has like merry Poppin
bags he just got endless beef sticks man
so could we try this can we try
switching outfits I'll do it I'll do it
you do it jacket you get the beef after
not before I'm beef sticked out man but
I'm not getting I'm not going to do the
naked thing I have to have someone come
and cover me up can we get a shield
please can we get someone to bring
something in here I don't know do that
can we please get something to cover him
up know he's not comfortable in his body
I don't feel comfortable doing
that I don't know what's the problem
give give him your shirt Ethan and I
think we have an outfit for Ethan over
here this way dude covering the camera
chill chill chill don't
look I'm watching I love Pop moms why
you wearing that shirt freak what shirt
says I love guys please shut up you're
going backwards
here that's not that's not kind you are
weird you walk around with beef sticks
in your pocket who does that I found
them
backstage shirt you took okay give me
the
shirt I thought this was a curtain but
it's actually his jacket it's
crazy here do you need my pants too yeah
I do I don't want my dick to pop
out would you like a beef stick no thank
you okay do I not wear a
shirt do
that I'm naked back here I didn't bring
underwe I I didn't know are you serious
oh nasty bro it's
tiny this is
warm where's the Hat
dude um
here but this for me thanks bro so let's
remember that expressing one's own
thoughts and their needs that's never
going to be an overreaction you know
it's never you're going be going too far
if you if you try how you truly feel
this is just zipper I think there's
a lack of okay he broke the zipper dude
no I didn't there's a lot of vulgarity
SN you can use the snaps which I'm not a
fan of you broke it Paul never I don't
give a dude put it up can you not judge
my show how about that you have a
problem with profanity that's your
problem not mine getting tired
idiot what are your credentials
bro what school did you
attend you him I was
homeschooled is that credential
credential yeah you got a PhD at home I
I'm not I never said I was a doctor so
don't put words in my mouth only thing
I'm putting in your mouth is beef
sticks
no all right it's
inappropriate can we get the shoes on
please fck why do you wear so much
takes forever to get dressed I designed
it myself dude guys please don't yell I
don't know if he's hitting me on purpose
you can drop it right you can drop it
I'm not ready yet I'm still changing I
can't figure out if the pants are
backwards or
forwards don't break those there's a one
of one watch your profanity shut up take
them on tour I have there literally two
right there it up did am I missing
something the top button idiot shut up
[Music]
dude name calling is never going to get
us any me button up the top you
idiot what do you mean I buttoned up all
the way how many buttons I'm not ready
yet how do I button it oh like I got it
I got it right there right
yeah don't touch me stop stop
take the blanket AB
wow
wow I look so Dum right Ethan Ethan you
look amazing so
bad
bro I can't do
this oh my God Ethan you look amazing
Oliver who wears this I wouldn't if I
wouldn't if I were you we'll change back
after but how are you guys feeling how
feel like I'm in The Matrix I feel
horrible dude so you feel pretty cool
this is the worst anything I've ever
been on I do feel kind of cool I feel
like a combination of the Matrix and
that one old lady who makes the costumes
and the incredible wow hair is not even
right
dude look at me stop don't touch me look
at me I'm fixing this wow see now we're
starting to get somewhere okay don't hit
Oliver Oliver sit hey you messed up the
hair you messed up the hair I'm not
going to get physical with you okay he
ol Oliver over here I'm trying to help
him oler over here over here over
here be I'm hungry I haven't eaten all
day okay well now what yeah what now how
does it feel so you know what you know
what I want to do right now the only
thing I can think of that would make
this better I want to can I do something
it depends what I want to try something
else I think I need to replace not just
the look and try to be in your shoes but
I think I need to run the show the way I
think it should be run that's a very
good idea Oliver I need to be you can we
please fly in my computer I want to try
something out should we fly Ethan out no
Ethan can stay okay he's giving me the
wrong Vibe so and then okay that's
interesting so and then when I'm
pretending to do you I'll I'll relaunch
the tickets but then when they don't
sell it all then they'll be I was
playing as you I think I need to go over
here though to do the show I want to do
you should maybe I'll pop
out can you take the beanie off I just
want to get no you're being so good out
there thank you Beach whoa yo what the
I didn't get you have another one
there's two here Jesus Christ man don't
touch those one of
What whose piece is this all right this
piece going spare let's cut the cameras
over to the host see where do I go here
I can't even see all right things fog up
man don't they do you have eye herpes
can you stop hi that's a thing did you
know I heard my name you got to keep the
camera on the host you can't just jump
around well your guest was speaking hi
Ela why are you co-hosting I'm not sure
what's happening my name can I speak for
a second her to call you this
isn't working we have to try this for
real hi cut the cameras back over here
well you're so annoying just do your
thing I can't do my thing when they're
putting can you please stop you
guys I'm about to
walk all right let try this out it's for
you yeah I'm trying here no the kinetic
sand is for your benefit that's why you
don't it's covering my face and my sick
ass
mustache can you please turn the music
off I'm trying to do something here okay
give him a shot guys you know what I
mean
just bear with me this is what it is for
me to you you got to walk in my shoes I
appreciate you guys trying to trying to
ruin his his uh takeover but let's he
let's hear him out I think he'll ruin it
himself all right you ready we're ready
from the top in five 4 3
2 hi my name is Ethan
Grime welcome to the Oliver three
podcast funny dude Grime I want to start
out with a little bit of a segment I
actually love to do I love Gossip I love
drama and I want to do Ethan Grimes
gossip hour so the first thing I want to
do is I want to pull up a couple
articles of some scandals some things
that have happened accusations can we
please bring up the first
article no one's going to bring it up
this is stand by what
kind of production all the works
when Ethan wants to do
it it's not actually true breaks all the
time what is that so this is an article
that I found yesterday that is about me
and my wife oh Fela Grime mhm so if
you look at this basically some
information that's come out in the last
24 hours is our company me and fela's
Company Teddy fresh is going to be
closing its doors after we lost $20
million of angel investor startup
Revenue because I Ethan grime
used the funds to build a water park
made exclusively for adults
only you did yeah we had to close the
doors on the teddy fresh company Ethan
are you even paying attention yeah call
Teddy fresh okay what are your thoughts
Oliver that sucks I'm sorry that
happened bro you're so disinterested
this is not how I gave you my
energy are you playing video games no
I'm listening intently all right we'll
move to the next
one there been a review of your album
Oliver you said Teddy fresh lost money
what's the joke or what's the there's no
joke okay do you know happen though yeah
I know you guys lose money all the time
talking about yourself all right let's
try this maybe something different this
can connect to you Oliver Oliver are you
listening yeah go ahead all right I saw
you had an album that came out today
congratulations thank you thank you man
man yeah this website peachfork reviewed
it do you know peachfork
peachfork oh yeah I've been reading them
for years yeah it's like an underground
type thing I got a 10 that's sick yeah
that's that's the highest number how do
it feel to have a Hit album the critics
are raving honestly it's it's a it's a
relief I thought it would never happen
it's almost like I'm in a dream like it
never did happen but it did happen I
actually got a perfect score from p
teach for I'm just it's so validating to
know that I got actually a good score
one of my albums okay I'm happy for you
man that's awesome thanks bro that's so
cool I'll be in I'll be in Argentina in
December did I mention that yeah well I
wish I could go but you know we have the
kids to take care of and you know how it
is man these kids go crazy and I'm
trying to sleep and fela's got a baby in
a bun in the oven thinking about calling
him Oliver named after you okay didn't
ask you to do that okay well the only
reason we didn't is because we thought
maybe it would upset you are you
listening Oliver
mhm okay uh let's try another article
this is one I found that's pretty crazy
uh so today after 6 years of research I
Ethan Grime was diagnosed with having an
extremely rare condition called micro
handia which means handia yeah well in
men it's known to make the hands
incredibly small oh it's very hard for
me you know it's hard for me to pick
things up so I can't play video games
with a normal controller so I have to
use a laptop
mhm uh any thoughts on this Oliver what
do you think anyone who plays video
games on a laptop has tiny hands well
those pictures says it all I have very
small hands oh I that guy
up um no listen is that unedited cuz
that's unbelievable that is that's
completely unedited this is a factual
size that is a little baby my hands are
small and I you know I think it's really
embarrassing I think it's really
embarrassing for you I wish you had
bigger hands it's okay but but you have
what you have and uh you work with what
you got beauty comes in all sh let say
this um to myself or to you I'll just
say this there's no
correlation I just want people to know
that okay all right well you know what
it seems like you're pretty
disinterested what are you talking about
well I just said you're playing video
games in the middle of our episode I can
multitask okay well I think I'm going to
do a little ad read go ahead all right
do you mind F
no God damn
it so
today the alliver three podcast is
brought to you
by slime energy drink a family-owned
company obsessed with living life to the
fullest founded on just two principles
live good feel good
in
2022 it was the number two sports drink
in all the world and with just 3,000
calories per bottle and 100 g of protein
when you want to get healthy get
slime when you drink a bottle of slime
you will feel the energy coursing
through not just your body but your soul
as well and now proud is a very large
understatement but slime is incredibly
proud and excited to bring their new
banana milk flavor to gas stations in a
corner store near you are you listening
you're coming you're doing the to gas
stations yeah we're doing gas stations
now we're moving up the food chain mhm
is this banana milk no this is blue GRE
Doo you want to try
it have a sip you should no you should
have some it's very good I'll have a sip
that's all you never asked is that just
Prime did Logan Paul pay you to promote
that it's called slime it's called slime
Ethan and it's a multi-million dollar
company tricep just multi-million I mean
I don't know if I can have it while
pregnant oh no no oh I got that don't
drink that no he one
so what else you have in the back well
it's funny you
ask this episode is also brought to you
by
oh
I got Nick Nicholls
pickles
[Music]
fresh crunchy kosher Dills from the
heart of Albuquerque New Mexico perfect
for any occasion whether it's a late
night snack or breakfast in the Bahamas
and remember when you're in a pickle
called Dr MC nickel why you selling
pickles also try our new peanut butter
pickles this message was approved by
Leading Beverly Hills pediatrician
Jeremiah Jeffrey Jr and the Jeremiah
Jeffrey Jr Foundation for artisanal
pickles snacks and
goods man campers
dude and
lastly this episode of the Oliver 3
podcast was brought to you
by goate
grow are you tired of your friends
having sick ass facial hair while you
can't grow measly little peach fuzz wait
are you talking about me stop whining
you crybaby
go te got you covered goatee grow
is the world's leading goatee hair
supplement one unique formula that was
designed to make the goatee grow 10
times thicker longer and
shinier with just one pill a day you can
achieve the perfect goatee without the
hassle of timeconsuming grooming
routines or expensive treatments goate
grow has helped over 6 million people
Nationwide wow who better to tell their
story than Oliver tree you want to say
anything about your product Oliver oh
yeah uh goat te grow is awesome because
as you know people don't want all the
facial hair just the goatee just the
part under the chin I've always wished I
could grow it that way we need go go we
need the goatee to grow exactly so we're
going to grow the goatee and
that's so ask your doctor if goate grow
is right for you side effects may
include but not limited to death
hospitalization disability permanent
brain damage pain redness swelling low
grade fever headache nausea vomiting
faue and goatee hair loss enter to win
your first Free bottle at goate grow.com
no liver problems nope zero liver
problems one shot one shot hold on throw
smoke also this podcast is powered by
alien boy
record oh I got this today on alien Boy
Records they have released the first
album ever
Oliver tree's third album alone in a
crowd Oliver are you listening I'm
promoting your album thanks bro that's
super exciting yeah we love what we love
everything we've been doing and um the
album's really good you guys all should
check it out
amazing are you listening Oliver or you
just playing
games all right can you tell us about
the album a little
bit so I shot I went to Serbia okay to
shoot this uh-huh and
um it's good there cuz the Labor's super
cheap all right well then no because you
know I'm on a budget because because I
spent all my money no I'm not that
because I SP no here I spent all my
money because I love my art and my craft
and that's what it's all about all right
we're moving on no wait I'm not done I'm
trying to honor you me okay so because I
spend all my money on my craft cuz I'm a
true artist okay I go to the place with
the cheapest labor all right all right
it's not just that this podcast was also
powered by alien boy
clothing so for those of you don't
know Oliver tree has been working on
this company and it's the highest of
high fashion it's been changing the face
of costumery design El you don't have
and there's no better clothing company
out there you got a big go ahead I
usually would throw out a random to
announ there will also be on the
lookout shared capsule collection in
collaboration with Teddy freshl for
Christmas
2028 what's happening I usually I just
trying I'm trying to play the role I
usually would say a random fact right
now um chat GPT says
$770 salary and Seria hold on hold on
where are you
going this is literally so chaotic you
guys just get the cameras on me all
right I'm okay all right I'm still
running the ad break it's a long ad
break really really like try to keep it
under 5 minutes yeah this podcast was
also powered by alien boy
books today marks the release of Oliver
tree's third Manifesto the ancient art
of go write a Manifesto due to selling
out the pre-order link within record
time 3 minutes the book is already
debuting on the New York Times
bestseller list now available at
bookstores worldwide and also before I
forget
this podcast was also powered by the one
the only alien boy films the greatest
production company ever
created are you listening Oliver I'm
plugging all your stuff dude thanks bro
this is going to be big for both of us I
know I know it's a big I'm going to plug
your stuff we're going to get views on
the
podcast let we need those it's already
taking too long just say I'm almost done
this is the end we have to make sure our
sponsors are taken care of you got to
put the sponsors first man please you
were so right okay so today alien boy
films just dropped Oliver tree's last
final music video ever made with you
okay so go make sure for Oliver tree s
you spam the comments just put the thing
on and just Spam as many comments as you
can m in the course of the listening of
the one play Just One play it's three
minutes long you just Spam the comments
upvote it fill it out can you do that
Oliver what do you need me to do spam
the
comments spam the comments with what the
With You music video that just came out
okay yeah we got it Dan we do it
okay can we turn this off what is going
on here it's just whale sounds to
relax dude I can't do this right now the
kids have been giving me up all night I
have a headache I don't want to hear
this is this it with you yeah it is with
You official music video what is going
on here that's what it's called with you
oh really wait this one how many views
does that have Dan this one has a ton
wow congratul 40 million views here W
conratulations it's your video I'm so
stoked man it's nice to see my hard work
pay
off all right dude have you ever heard
the brown noise it's good can we can we
stop everything let's try something else
this the ad reads over okay can we put
the hey hello Oliver are you listening y
let's shut it off okay it's Clos I want
to have a serious interview mm I'm
trying to make this a serious interview
and I'd appreciate it if you just take a
moment just give me some respect okay do
you want me to take over this is
unwatchable
bro bro I'm just getting started I have
the greatest show
planned I'm not going to talk about
Tylenol or Ibuprofen but I have some
good stuff go ahead so you guys trying
to help people it's not that fun very
Sav the life mhm but that many people
watching you don't think I probably help
chat gbt themselves you could have used
my advice bro all right let me speak
You're the one with the St
before the show
backstage we gave Oliver tree a
paternity test it was a little DNA test
and today we addressed the
controversy Oliver tree has 12 kids with
five different
women which ties him officially with
Nick Cannon Round of Applause wow well
you know know me I love unprotected sex
with lots of women that's just what I
like to do Oliver tree I wanted to say
we have found a potential child that
could be your
son so today we did the test and
um bring why did this arrive at my
apartment this is the test yeah I never
gave you my address or anything I just
send it
in okay I I would like an answer on that
first uh I'm your employer of course I
have your address where do I send your
past just open it send it to me I need
it to be brought out here so we can
announce this is the most pregnant
I've Seena do in a minute she brought
two bags W of cheddar cheese Ruffles two
bags that's I was going to say if
anybody wait heila this is important I
need you to come sit right here no this
is important let's get on with this
taking too long for this to work we need
to be able to have heila sitting over
here their
husband
I can't F this her she's an independent
woman the tests have come
in the DNA diagnosis
Center has arrived
[Music]
mhm is so good ruffle ched got the first
test in can we get a
closeup pregnancy test can we get a
close-up on this you know I don't I
can't you know I'm a
I can't take pregnancy tests you know
that right we did the test who did the
test because that I don't think that
works
on who's we I don't think that works
with testicled people or uh it only
works with biological men can I say
that how would I say
that it it only works with biological
women is that how I could say that while
being
inclusive
people who men you can see people who
menray don't cut away I'm
talking sorry you can see this has
clearly been used gross and we do have a
result here that's
[Applause]
disgusting keep the drum roll
[Music]
going in the case of
8-year-old Oliver tree
Jr Oliver
you are the father wow oh my
God what you're a father I'm a father
you're a father welcome to the club I
don't okay Dad all right wow I'm so
excited know I'll be honest though I'm a
little scared to be a dad because I'm
always traveling I don't make any money
I have unpr sex all the time how am I
going to raise this kid right I I will
teach you me and Fila we know a lot
about this so I wanted to potentially
see if you would be interested in
talking to all ol Jr wait you brought an
actual kid oh wow okay I brought your
son bring him
out Oliver Jr make some noise Oliver's
son is
here come over
here Oliver Jun get come come this way
yeah I want to get a shot of him cuz
Okay now right this way here you can sit
down have you met Oliver your father
before
uh here talk to this Mike yeah a few
other times you met him can I ask you um
what is your namei his name is Oliver
junor are you are you being forced to do
this no okay um now hold on are you sag
does he is he part of sag cuz they're on
strike still he's not he's not tied of
the Union at
all oh that's my that's my dog Alfredo
you can say him he's a bring up Alfredo
you like dogs or you don't like dogs I
love dogs you want to say hi to him
bring him up come here his name's
Alfredo he's very nice he loves
everybody I love chicken alfredo chicken
alfredo that's what I'm talking oh he's
giving kisses what a good boy
Alfredo now there are Rule now there's
you know there's protections against
having kids on
set I don't know anything about this I
didn't know that ex my he's your own son
are do we have like doesn't he need like
a teacher on set or something or we've
got a teacher over in the back he was
just got out of class you did the class
are you did your homework
uh yeah yeah yeah he's been working very
hard so he could come and do this so I
wanted to ask you some questions Oliver
Jr is that okay yeah you mind if I ask
some questions about your father and you
yeah so okay first of
all are you proud of your
father I'm very proud you are keep talk
louder into the mic we can't I couldn't
hear what you said I'm very proud very
proud thanks buddy that's nice of you
you do know he put out his album today
right yes I do I listen I listened to
the to the album yesterday really all of
them what did you think you you listen
to all of them that's so nice it was
good what time did you listen to it in
the day about uh I listened to it last
night didn't he release it last night
yeah you're a slick you're a slick kid
man you nailed it um so what was your
favorite song on the new album did you
like any of the songs your dad made on
it or was it not really your favorite I
don't have a favorite song wow because
they're all great oh my God thank you
man that's so nice that's so nice your
son likes your music man yeah you might
be the only one I really appreciate that
cuz like if my son believes in me then
that gives me all the strength in the
world thank you so much son thank you
and what is your you don't have a one
favorite song out of all the music by
your dad there's not one song no I don't
know I don't really have any favorites
you don't even listen to the music do
you yeah I listen to the music okay let
me I hey don't push man that's my son
dude don't be I'm trying to get I'm
trying to connect you to I'm trying to
make a connection don't try to ENT trap
him like oh you don't even let don't
give him a hard time I'm saying be nice
this think you're ever around for him I
have I have actually I can I think I
remember some of the names I don't
really me didn't really memorize him but
there's like with you I think something
oh my God the new one that came out
today yeah and then there's like well
the music video for it right that was
your favorite one but and then they and
then know stuff Invisible Man and wow
that's underground cut that one is
that's a new one no one heard that one
yet yeah and then it's also like it's
also
like you son don't don't don't worry you
got two he getting stressed that's
really good two is good two is a really
good I that's two more than I expected
um so I wanted to say more than I can
name what do you want to be when you
grow up
uh a an artist a sing
really make some
noise
noise what' you say noise noise he says
noise noise he said make noise trying to
make some noise to make some noise so
you want to you want to be a musician
mhm really well you know what they say
the Apple doesn't fall far from the tree
do you like um beef
jerkey yeah I love slim JY do you want
this it's really good yes yes I want it
here I'll I'll just get it started for
you and then you can open it yourself
there they go it's really good do you
like Ruffles cheddar Ruffles these are
good too yeah I like Ruffles you want
something to drink sure water you like
so we have like all kinds of diet sodas
like Coke Zero and stuff do you like
those yeah I do but I just feel like
water you just want water can we get a
water do you like it with ice or no
bring it with water and a straw we need
a water do we have a straw with ice and
a straw please maybe some lemon in there
you like Lem yeah I love bring some
lemon
too can I get a sod too we have ice
cream in the in the freezer also really
good
flavor I don't really like ice cre yeah
I don't either really cake well well I
do like some kinds of cake but I don't
cake that much what kind of sweets do
you
like I like
like I forgot what I like what I like I
like I this thing called like tart it's
like oh you like the sweet and sour no
there's like
Tarts U with the fruit on it and then
they're like like stuff and then like
they're like you know you like the fruit
cakes or like the sweet and sour do you
like the Nerds like sweet and sour stuff
cuz we have some of that too I'm just
saying going to make you comfortable
yeah I do like nerds is that good nice
this is amazing thank
you I'm I'm so excited to be able to
connect you guys I just said I like this
is beautiful you want to try them this
is great this is groundbreaking actually
I'll take this actually take you can
have it son thank thank you so
much I didn't I thought we were going to
get the therapist together water it's
com okay jeez Oliver calm down I didn't
want to get served first here you go
sweetheart Oliver please be nice with
the straw wow look at that so Oliver
junor you want to be an artist huh
you think you got what it takes how was
school today did you go to school today
what time is it or
summer what year is it what it's not
it's not summer it's not summer so wait
did you go to school today no you didn't
no did you get off cuz of this yeah holy
smokes that's awesome dude high
five thank you so much thank you so dude
of course next time we'll have you too
do you not like school no but how come
sometimes I like some things like
science and stuff you like science yeah
that's
fun well I wanted to say you have a
dream to be artist like your father
Oliver he said he's into science do you
not listen would you prefer to be a
scientist and there's there's no right
answer here I would prefer to be science
you would I wouldn't you would not oh I
would not really what kind of artist
would you like to be I don't know like
the same as like is like kind of the
music you make really Oh you mean your
dad
makes yeah I'm talking to you Dad no
your dad's there yeah oh yeah right wait
we're diding a we're doing a little
switch room this is confusing I know
it's confusing but your dad here he just
put out this album this wasn't my idea
for the record this was his idea so I
don't know what that means I just wanted
to say you mean your idea your idea I
guess if you want to get deep enough I'm
yeah yeah it was my idea it was my idea
but then that's confusing
cuz but then it is still your idea that
guy the guy who's sitting right there
who usually wears this outfit this was
his idea I had nothing to do with this
this was the idea of the therapist it's
just as you what grade are you in I'm in
fifth fifth grade nice so you're you're
going to be going to middle school soon
right next grade yeah that's cool are
you excited mhm yeah middle school is
fun I feel like it's a big step up from
elementary school M that's good so I
wanted to say since you want to be an
artist is there anything you want to
sing for
us just a little bit just tiny snippet
is there anything you would care to
maybe get this artist career started
early H what what was
it what's happening twinkle twinkle
little star how I wonder where you are
up above the so I forgot the word in the
sky twink T twinkle little star how I
wonder where you
are Oliver Jr you're you have the
potential to be anything you want to be
no dream is too big whether it's a
scientist or to be an engineer a doctor
or an artist like your father you could
do anything man just know that thank you
for coming today you're welcome Make
some noise for Oliver Jr thank you
awesome
man
um do you have a I wonder kids your age
do you guys use smartphones already or
not yet no you didn't get one yet I just
like playing on my tablet you get the
tablet nice that's what my son has he he
loves his tablet you you have another
son you play games on it hold on mod D
stop what games do you play on the
tablet I don't know I like building
stuff in Minecraft nice dude I don't
know Happy Happy Wheels is pretty fun oh
I play I used to play that Happy Wheels
and uh what else do I have I forgot you
ever play this game my singing monsters
you ever heard of that one no it's
really fun I play it with my son he he
loves it you should check it out I think
you would like it it's really
cool well I think that's pretty much all
the time we have here is there anything
else you want to share anything you want
to say Oliver Jr oh yeah what do you
want to say that that's all the time we
have here okay before we go do you want
to show any moves that your father
showed you like a specific movement that
your dad used to do that you're inspired
by oh yeah let's see
it hey wait over there yeah don't bark
him or his man be play my
son that was was I think D sick that was
awesome Make some noise for Oliver Jr
thank you thanks for I so nice to meet
you man oh you got me rex have fun in
middle school you're going you're going
to crush it over there that is
amazing have a good one man appreciate
you buddy nice to meet you nice meeting
you he's the real dad by the way just he
said he's on a tight schedule he's got
to
go well thanks for making time for us I
know you got school off today come on
oh just got better things to do like
playing m he says I have better things
to do like playing Minecraft fair enough
cold well thank you for coming we
appreciate it fair enough I'm glad we
got you the day off dude thank you bye
man nice meeting you good kid
bye really sweet kid yeah well you have
I think it's in your DNA you're a sweet
guy you're an awesome dude
Oliver thanks and uh then let me tell
you this Ethan you've lost so much
weight you look amazing you look so
young thank you and um I was going to
say you look amazing as well Oliver you
lost yourself thank you that's nice that
we both did that I'm super happy for you
and Ela is there anything you want to
say to Oliver before he leaves on his
World Tour seven continents three months
what's the um anything you want say luck
on your
tour hope don't blood again yeah
hopefully you're not you won't get sick
at all hopefully no if cancel it would
be good to be like oh yeah sorry guys I
was blood again and puking
blood that might work if they just were
honest with them yeah if if it was up to
me I would be more honest with my fans
about when I have to cancel and just
being honest about when there's shows
that I already know I'm going to cancel
you know if it was up to me I'd take it
more serious if you know I plan on
taking it more I get what you're saying
that's awesome is there anything else
you want to share lots of water lots of
sleep not going out the night before
definitely using protection well you're
sober too so that makes it easy you're
not actually going out right or are you
can I see that again wait hold
on wow that was very cool Oliver I like
that is there anything you want to share
about the album Oliver anything you want
to say watch cuz I I do want to watch
more yeah I'd love to see some of your
videos and I'd love to hear you tell me
about them a little bit and I could
maybe critique them a little bit all
right so which is the one the one that
you wanted us to watch well I I
understand you put out a new video today
it was with you yeah with you right
right let's watch that one so where did
you film these videos exactly I remember
you said something briefly but what
Junior is coming back oh what's up buddy
wow remember what is it oh something to
remember oh wow thank
you wow that's very kind it's the first
time I've ever gotten a gift on this
show that's not good oh thank you oh
thanks buddy thanks man that's real nice
of you wow did you paint this yourself
that's so cute look at that this
guy it's it's uh Dr bone is that Anthony
fantano no it's Dr
bone hey thank you so much thanks buddy
you Oliver junr ladies and gentlemen
thank you so much what a king this is
beautiful I'm so grateful you're a good
kid thank you you're a good kid
wow the bone Zone it says put this
up so wanted to watch um well I would I
love your videos so much Oliver and uh
one thing I will say is miss you no with
that new video you dropped today I loved
what you were doing though I mean some
of the shots were
incredible so you you directed this
yourself yeah I went to Serbia and you
wrote it too and you also did you say
you produced it apparently that is
honestly insane and so is this what is
going on here with this shot you were
getting saying you were getting into
fashion designing is this tied to it
wow okay so here I'm doing it it's kind
of a metaphor for when I was
blood and basically it's I needed a A
Tail
of Hospital
coats to clean up the massive uh pool of
blood that followed me wherever I went
it's quite Grim but it is what it
is okay
interesting and what is this what's
going on here where where is this blood
coming from is this blood is that fruit
juice now here's where I
um well I wanted to ask you this really
quick what's up with the hairstyle what
is why did you go with this
hairstyle um why did
I cuz it looks like Lord FAA you look
kind of funny I'm not going to lie right
I'm not say anything but you look really
dumb yeah you do look dumb I didn't want
to say that but why the mini me thing I
don't know know about that one it's
literally
himself right all right let's turn the
video off it's pretty cool what was the
one you want me to see watch the last
shot yeah watch the last shot here you
go you missed you already you already
missed it dude let me go back let me go
back this
[Music]
yeah yeah this is the last shot this is
my favorite
[Music]
shot this looks
crazy that's crazy that we got that shot
that's the craziest shot ever bro that's
nuts yeah I can't believe we did that we
pulled that off man that's
crazy yo how did I do
that what
the whoa you are very talented I will
give you that all right so let me here's
my other favorite one I'll play you so I
just want to say I want to watch Essence
I get it I get why you went to Serbia I
get why you spent so much money and time
making this stuff you really are doing
something special and unique can I play
you um I mean what do you think F I
don't want to I agree I think this is so
nobody else has ever done that you think
so mhm mhm can I play you Essence this
is my favorite one off the album and I
think you're going to like it it's got a
Twist so is that you sing that doesn't
sound like you sound like your normal
voice lab or something is this someone
else oh wait who's super computer hold
on dude just
[Music]
watch a massive
scoliosis is that part of the
video yeah this is this was one of the
craziest shots we got in Serbia it was
like massive and I don't know how we
pulled it off but you want to see it
again this was crazy it to millions of
dollars we had CR and was so
good a massive
what the is this
dude this is
my what the is this for
real turn this off dude
respectful I put this
together for you this is
you're pissing me off
right now dude I'm about to come over
there and put you to a Full Nelson this
is Bross be respectful this is my show
you're coming on my show and you're
going to dises turn this off right
now I'm leaving all right all right all
right I'm going no no no it's
fine I'm done here man you make
a ridicule Ethan Ethan Ethan
Ethan sit down I'm so confused bro I'm
just trying to share my work you
wait why are you angry I'm just sharing
my work I don't understand what's
happening I was trying to share my work
with Ethan Klein and he why did he get
angry Ethan Grime yeah it's Ethan Grime
Grime whatever where's theist to grab my
portrait done by Oliver
Jr my other fa my other favorite is fair
weather also I'm taking
this what don't take that you can't take
that that's not yours yeah mine take no
that's not yours to take that's insured
I have that
documented I'm done Oliver you can't
leave the gate you don't you don't
Oliver I will press charges that is not
yours to
take we have that we have that
documented in our fire Insurance MH so
huh dude I wanted to watch more videos
man don't you want to promote
all
right weirdo I was trying to I was
trying to play along I got on the outfit
I was being him I don't understand what
more he wants from me I did everything
he
wanted maybe to make it up for to him
maybe you could like review his album or
something okay let's review this track
Fairweather friends okay this is one of
my other fa uh favorite ones and it's
something Oliver would know something
about being being a fair weather friend
mhm am there it
[Music]
is Bones I am
rectangular oh this one's catchy feel no
I am
rectangular and you are a circle I am
rectangular I feel no hole I am
rectang
ARA I'm playing dude what do you want
I'm playing your music video
That's not the song this isn't that
isn't the song the
video
that's I really love this music video
yeah dude I I think no it's really deep
that you're rectangular but you don't
holes in you why it's the best song
you've written
you know hey there's a special place in
hell for people like
you you want to promote your thing I'm
never coming back here you didn't
promote the tour dat you put the it's
right here it's right here olivertree
olivetree.com it's not Olive tree.com
godamn it what are you talking about
Olive if I type in your name Oliver
tree the first result on
Google is oh that's the cells that's
weird I don't know what that is bro is
not.com yeah Ethan dude look at the URL
Ethan stop what's wrong you keep sending
people to buy Bibles that's not my
website is this in your business I no I
had nothing to do with all Tree Bible
they bought the site before I could get
it is this a new vertical for you the
Bible salesman thing no I I'm not doing
any more the religion stuff I don't know
anything about it there is good money in
that that could be a way to find your
music videos helping millions of people
read and study the Bible that's terrific
man that's nice you're doing something
it's nice you're doing something turn
this off dude Vladimir
Putin children and teens what is your
problem dude all right here's
your is this your website well then tell
me the real one ol this is it Oliver
dream music I couldn't you didn't tell
me music was in the URL bro I just typed
your name get a better URL I can't
afford to get the real one hey well then
then stop spending so much money you can
actually get a good URL and don't have
to buy a Bible every time I want to
listen to your music all right so what
do I do alone the scroll down scroll
down alone in the crowd down dude alone
in the crowd available now everywhere
everywhere it just came out today and I
came out of all the places in the world
to this podcast didn't ask which used to
be my favorite podcast all right so and
I want to say this hila MH I am a hila
Kleiner thank you and you are the only
reason that I watch this show I'm I'm an
oliv our trer stop uhuh thank you so
that's so nice yo there's what is deer
these
[Applause]
nuts you up for
that wait that was off camera you crazy
B no no violence kill her hey no she's
pregnant no violence
I don't I don't know who to defend who's
the really e where's the therapist I
thought he was going to who's the really
e cheers my dude say uncle never say
uncle where's Bobby Lee when you need
him I throw my feet defense take my
socks I got a t love you all
right I'm done here dude that's
no he started he started being
inappropriate I'm taking the socks are
you okay El I'm taking his with
everybody okay he started grabbing me
inappropriately when we were doing the
D's Nuts I did not and I thought we were
having a special moment and of course
you Ru socks these are Ethan Grime socks
and I'm taking the Ethan Grime pill take
my socks the most valuable thing you
have yeah I'm okay I'm so sorry about
that your husband is an awful person did
he hit you El
no did he hit you
no how do I get the out of here
it's a ma walking in circles
what are you going to do with that
pillow I'm going to take this pillow and
I'm going to burn it dude all
right hoe Mandel made that pillow
Mandell my ass good luck ever being on
his show idiot a real
celebrity what is dieser though
I'm taking I'm taking AI e too no you're
not what is dieser can anyone tell me
that was like $5,000 streaming service I
never heard of it yeah what's special
about it I I don't know it's another
another thing it's for smaller
artists right it's for people with
less uh audience members than
[Music]
usual it's for you know underground
artists yeah
all right so ol Oliver tree music I
believe and then how do you get the
tickets then uh if you scroll down Does
it show the tour I can't scroll I'm
literally trying to scroll down I see
the bar on the right going down does
move oh maybe you have to ex exit hit
the exit what a dumb website wait hold
on look at this weite window literally
he's trying to steal AI in right now
wait hey hey he's definitely yeah he's
should I stop what the is yeah if
you could stop him dude I'm taking it no
you're not you're not what the wait
show how effed up this browser is yeah
I've never seen this before I think it's
like a popup that you need to close
that's like a free uh template from
WordPress I refreshed it it doesn't work
hit the X hit the X the corner this what
a oh my God is that's the dumbest
a no you're not dude I'm trying to find
Show tickets there it is there it is
there it is all right here
October
Australia Ethan how much a ticket cost
for this they're like I don't know
$90 bro what is it $90 how much are your
tickets for your shows I don't know less
than that probably for general admission
um you guys just want to say uh the ga
section was 69 69 69 yeah I had
everything priced out at that nice uh
just so we know the only good parts of
the show is hila Ai and the rest of the
crew that does all the hard heavy
lifting thank you while Ethan
does nothing thank you so shout out to
the entire crew so you're in
Australia want to say the crew is so
amazing hey love welcome bro thank you
brother welcome to America he got here
and I'm so proud of you for making it
thank you France got here with your help
yeah what' you say you got here with
your help yeah I did BR I know I'm
Greatful and then Dan thank you for
being the glue that holds this whole
thing together Belgium Netherlands ger
God Bless you that's it honored that
you've been here all these years and
still putting up with Ethan's
wait hold on why does it only go till
Olivia incredible job with all the power
points I'm so grateful that we get to
share this moment together you're going
to every continent you're just going to
Australia and Europe I'm going to Bal
Indonesia tomorrow dog there's shows
that aren't on there and there's other
things I'm going to that I can't even
speak about and I'm taking trips as well
for my own self okay but I'm thinking
it's cool you're taking trips for
yourself Sam I just want to say you make
the best in the world
piatas thank you is that really you
making that it is me they're so
incredible that Piata you made of Ethan
that I destroyed was the best piece of
art I've ever seen well who else is over
there I can't even see who's hating
behind
oh hey Z you why do you hate you
jerk dude putting on the clown
sounds I'm trying to give a serious
interview but you know what
congratulations I'm playing with
Portugal the Man I'm proud of you than
buddy I love you man I love you too but
no more of that clown oh
we'll talk and then of course I have to
say
this I don't want to say this what are
you playing
dude go
ahead cam I want to thank you for
helping piece together some of the most
incredible designs of Our Generation a
just want you to know he's such a talent
I what you made the Oliver tree the
Oliver 3 show he made that logo he was
so
talented and and thank you yesterday you
checked in with me about my arm and
everything thank you very much you're
very
sweet I just want to say this before I
leave the only good part of the show
besides hila is AI Ian and Ian I wish I
could say more about you but you know as
a guy who was in the Kanye West Forums
on Reddit you totally screwed us man
when you left the the whole Reddit Forum
collapsed on itself definitely don't go
everyone who didn't get tickets for h3's
little mini show you can come on down to
my show I'll take car you best out of
your life that's nice you see is there
anything else on uh uh oh yeah here's
something I wanted to thank you for by
the way um thank you by the way to my
good friend Oliver
tree for reposting doing pretty good
better than any of your videos videos
from alpha red
pill what a piece of I am and what
a loser and how I CH thank you to I
destroyed you dog like every
time I destroy you thank you to
posting that to all your socials I did
so good my only good post in the summer
thanks man yeah I you came in here you
came in here with really good um oh my
God look at you look like an idiot dude
with that little hat you made a
fool out of yourself dog I was wearing
your clothes D you always do I
clowned you so hard on your own shitty
little show hey by the way congrats on
6.5 million views the only time you get
views when you talk about I've got
videos with hundreds of million views
I'm
not where are they go down go down a
little bit this shit's all album promo
of course I'm taking it all down million
bro yeah go down see what the real
looks like 100,000 300,000 album promo
go down before the cycle sucks all
that shit's coming down even that stea
one has way more no it
doesn't this one the right of it dude
just keep talking about it's like 9.8
million it's working really good for go
down look at the real before I did
all this garbage posting it's promo here
let's go read through the comments I
love this post I'm never taking it down
I think people arey look at this I know
he he's too good I got him so good he's
really hitting close to I beat you at
your own game buddy I
beat you at your own game yeah cool
you're really going to court the best
people to watch you yeah you are you you
are such a judgmental guy who are you to
judge people let's make another one of
these videos right now is
actually looking for guests if you want
to go over there I would love to I know
you would scumbag all I'm going to say
is I don't use the internet and all I
will say is watching all this content
that is the best video listen to this he
wasn't even trolling he was genuinely
upset as a fan himself who that's what
the com one I was a fan I'm I'm what
they call a fallen fan 23,000 likes bro
I'm like a fallen angel dog I bring
Darkness look at this man about a
quarter of the world needs someone to
call them out like this straight up we
need more friends negativity everyone's
just calling each other out now all
people are doing is just they know when
someone's spitting straight facts
dog
yeah thanks man cool like I don't get
enough
Flack my supposed friend is posting this
propaganda first of all friends
overstatement you know what you're
you're a fair weather friend
thanks man you're guy who shows up when
you need me and by the way when you want
to promote something guess what he
didn't just post it on YouTube shorts no
he had to spread it all around let's see
bro I post everything everywhere of
course Instagram I love this song
Instagram wow
I love how many rightwing okay so that
person gets it I love how many
right-wing Pages posted this not knowing
it was a bit it wasn't a bit that's a
real piece of art right there
shared this I came on I got you to dress
up like me and then I completely said
the facts we've been all waiting for you
know who shared this post who Hitler
Youth all right dude those are your fans
brother congratulations I have no idea
what that is joke or not he has a point
Ethan changed so much for the
worst thanks bro these people they're
spinning straight facts too dog it's
just the harsh reality no I appreciate
it bro you should follow some of them
back but it wasn't just Instagram no he
kept going it was on
Twitter who posts videos to twitter
anyway I know well dude I don't even my
Twitter's obsolete so at least that one
did good there it is yeah yeah even on
here well he doing pretty good hat off
to you for calling him out top comment I
love it I should like that one I didn't
even see that you know that guy is he's
a member of the um the fascist movement
for America really yeah that's well you
know what's interesting in my music
video there's writing that says death to
Fascism so suck on that well they
probably think you're talking about
socialism and they actually want to rep
you as their fascist leader you
pig
musini you don't scare me one bit
looking like that you look like a
clown hey is that the guy from
that Old Tik Tok sound no one uses
anymore they were talking about you
that's your that's they were talking
about you dud you that sound you that
sound retweet bro you're the guy they're
talking about take that off don't
retweet that yes this don't you
dare Ethan seriously stop it's too far
it's too far don't do it don't
hit the God damn it Ethan I swear to God
if you don't know race right now I'm
walking Ethan and then no that wasn't
enough he posted the Tik Tok too t no
don't show the Tik Tok Ethan like you a
demon for that bro bro we'
posted beefs whole career that's
the entire only things we've ever posted
what makes this different because you
ripped this from like I I didn't know
what it's from it's literally
from it's ripped from your
podcast dude dude they made a
compilation and that you probably went
to the Facebook group like
neo-nazis against H I don't even have
anything to do with this that's the
difference the difference is I
got content we filmed on your shitty
little podcast you can do that and I ran
all
[Music]
the
PA
oh
god oh and then if that wasn't enough
all right if if he's not if he dude if
Oliver's not trying to dog whistle to uh
right-wing Fanatics he had he
[Music]
had
do
[Laughter]
it
stay Bas by Ryan Air wait that's not
real is it the Ryan Air isn't that a
isn't that wait wait wait wa wait wait
wait what out wait hold on Ryan Air
verified page said base
wait like the airline yes this is
verified Ryan Air what's said based on
that video what is this fly right I
don't know what it's verified the money
I always fly right in air catch flights
not feeling yes I do it's the m is that
in South uh Southwest hold yeah is this
is this real Spirit Group Travel for
groups of 15 plus family bundle what the
is this hey you can finally take
your hardworking employees on a trip you
dick you would know anything
about treating your employees with
dignity loser hey we're going
around the world Paul what does he even
get his own room or does he sleep on the
floor your hotel room Paul is coming
around the world with me dog yeah who
cares who cares if you're going around
the room if you have to sleep on the
bathroom floor
idiot all right well it seems like we're
not getting anywhere positive you're
talking about negative energy let's Let
It Go let's let's I've apologized to you
many times why is Ryan Air talking
Ryan Air is legendary and they're
based Ryan airplane they're just falling
out of the out of the air you understand
it we're like falling out of the air
honestly I wish he'd listen to this Vice
his comedy bits and creative projects
are always his best work oh that's nice
actually hey Honestly though I will say
this are you ever going to make more
videos on the H3 Productions no
why it's none of your business you
fell off that's why don't do
don't try to make another compilation
we're going to get good footage
boys let's talk about you exploiting
workers in I will say I will say this I
will say this Putin what think about
Taiwan I want to share something is
Taiwan part of China or no I have no
idea about any of this dude I'm
literally the dumbest guy you've ever
met sound like Nazi sympathizer I don't
know any I don't even know what you're
saying but I will say this of course
don't I was a fan of H3 podcast before
it was a podcast I was made one song
yo dude spicy mayonnaise Survivor just
took it down in the comments bro I've
got many many platinum songs many
platinum songs he's heard one song I
have many I have like you know I have
songs with multiple billion streams
that's okay I don't need to get your
approval but let me say this I'm trying
to compliment you for one second I was a
fan from the beginning in Santa Cruz and
I remember kids coming up to me and say
dude you got to check out this guy you
remind me of him and then I watched some
of your stuff and I was like like me is
funny well you look like me
right now and guess what it's crazy that
I'm here sitting with you oh you being
nice for real yeah I'm trying to just
share a moment of sentimental thanks bro
it's crazy because I know there is some
Origins and Santa and we've touched on
these things in the past but yeah all
these years how many podcasts have we
done together we actually counted this
is six which no we've done six full
episodes but how many have I popped up
in in uh been annoying oh oh then it's
got to be probably like 10 no it's way
more than that I I called so many times
I called in in like casinos and
different things yeah that was awesome I
think 15 20 times was the whole thing
with the carriage too uh well how many
how many tours have you had cuz that's
probably how many times you called in I
we'll promote tours multiple times
that's true hey guys I'm calling you
from the casino anyway.com I have shows
in Vegas well I owed my uncle a lot of
money that was part of that but I will
say this it's pretty magical that
someone who you know came up growing up
watching your stuff can be here sitting
with you 15 interactions later through
these different episodes six full
episodes we're talking about like maybe
15 hours of content just in those six
episodes let alone the other on so I
feel incredibly grateful to be part of
this family I consider myself in the
family thank and I'm honored to be a
part of this Kila it's so inspiring to
watch you grow and Blossom as a
fashionista not just with the stuff you
make but also with the stuff you wear
and the way you've been presenting
yourself is very inspiring so I'm so
happy that you guys found each other and
that you both are able to have a family
together I'm I'm scared if there's like
a Twist to The Twist is the dagger in my
back your I want to
say I want to be officially I want the
world to know I am the Godfather of
Scotty no that's the only
twist okay let me say this I'm so glad
you finally did it guys I think you're a
create I think you're a creative
Juggernaut I think you're I was waiting
for where's the twist here Juggernaut
what is what do you mean by that you're
like a tour to force of creativity like
you're unstoppable yeah
mediocre
it's like a train that never stops I
have no friendship no life and that's
one thing I will say is I admire you
guys found love I'm trying to give you a
compliment now and you won't shut the
up sorry I don't do these
compliments very well you're you're a
creative Juggernaut thank you not many
people in this day and age will commit
themselves to their art like you do put
your limb put your life whatever there
is of it you put your money you put it
all down for Love of the Game not many
people can do that and you do it lovely
ly too like we saw the views aren't that
good and that shit's not cheap and
that's what I love about you views are
down
heavily thank you but that's that's what
that's to your credit thank you yeah and
I do love that we have that Santa Cruz
connection I know Santa Cruz is a
special place and it makes sense knowing
that you come from a tweaker City like
that yeah that's like the main I just
went to school there I wasn't born there
it's it's a heroin Hot Spot there Heavy
D
and I'm I'm lucky to be alive here
standing before you I barely did and I
was so close I had near-death
experiences and I was a junkie an addict
yes bro I had multiple interactions and
I you were you really did you were junky
BR there was times that I had done
heroin multiple days in a row really I
play with fire I was an idiot kid
growing up high school through high
school I was were heroin in high school
I Santa Cruz is crazy it's crazy so C
and I want to say that that's not to
glamorize that but I will M it's not
about trying to be like I'm not an
addict anymore it's about finding the
right addictions to fill those empty
holes in my soul and try to be addicted
to something that can be positive and
inspire people and hopefully make the
world a little more colorful and my
intention is never to bring Darkness
even though for you in that moment and I
apologize with the I had no idea though
I don't use the internet I'm not reading
comment sections I don't know what's
going on but just knowah I did we
sidebar yeah you just happened to fall
on a Hitler Youth against Ethan Klein we
hate Jew's Facebook page yes I'm not
involved with any of it but I will say
this I just want to say people who
struggle with addiction which is most
people it's about learning to find those
things that bring you happiness fill
those empty holes in your Void that
doesn't self-destruct and doesn't harm
others find something positive find
something you can bring a little color
to this dark world and I just want to
say if a guy like me a tweaker guy like
me from Santa Cruz could be standing
here with the most incredible couple on
YouTube well you could do whatever that
is inspiring I didn't know you went
through drug drug problem for sure I
would do like seven drugs at a time wow
really yeah I was very hardcore I had a
few different near-death experiences and
I got kicked out of my house I used to
sell drugs to survive my parents they
threw all my out they're like you
can't live here anymore and I was
selling hard drugs to survive what was
there a rock bottom or how did you get I
mean The Burning Man
story I told you the Burning Man story
maybe not I don't think you told I never
told it basically I went on a family
vacation to Burning Man which is the
most Santa Cruz sentence you went with
your fam yeah wow and one time I came
home and they had a whole Cola of weed
sitting on the table and I was like
what's going on I didn't even know that
they smoked or anything like we're
making brownies for Burning Man and so
with that me and my family went on this
trip and I brought a shitload of acid
and it was the most strong LSD that I
ever had and my friend he got it
straight from the chemist and it was
like the most pure and how old were you
at the time this was when I was 17 I
just turned 17 so before my senior year
in high school and I basically was there
to try to party have fun but I also like
wanted to experience the burn the night
of the burn with my family every night I
would go out and do different do Ecstasy
at the Raves blah blah blah um and long
story short I was supposed to meet my
parents Rondevu for the night of the
burn and I took a bunch of acid and I
was thinking it was weakened cuz I had
taken it to other festivals and the heat
can damage it and I took a bunch and I
just was going to take it with my family
I was hoping but basically I missed the
Rendevous spot cuz I went back to get
water and I realized I missed them and
so I just engulfed into the most heavy
duty LSD trip of my life and basically
what happened was I had some of those
brownies in my backpack and those
brownies were so strong you would just
pass out if you took like more than a
little bit of it your parents made that
mhm Santa Cruz you know that's next yeah
I my mom would like make brownies for my
friend's mom who had cancer like
medicinal you know what I mean so like
there's a background with that kind of
stuff um but she had made the brownies
for this experiment experience with the
family and anyways when I was super high
on LSD I was so high that I was super
hungry and I was like usually you don't
get hungry but I was like oh brownie is
cool I didn't even remember that there
was weed in them normally you just get
bloodshot eyes and pass out they're way
too strong but instead I was so high and
acid you can't really fall asleep and so
I just started having these lucid dreams
where everything was a movie playing and
I think obviously there was a ton of
acid but I've done acid like maybe 50
times and nothing had ever experienced
yeah damn I was heavy duty into it for a
while and um psychedelics in general um
but long story short it just started
being movies playing and I couldn't see
real life it was just movies playing and
this whole scenario played out
where I watched myself die and I
basically I overheated I was taking my
clothes off and I started running
through the desert I couldn't even see
around me and basically there was a
outside fence in the parameters of
Burning Man the snow fence orange type
of snow fence and I couldn't even see it
I ran just flipped over it my body was
covered in Cuts I had Cuts even on my
dick my whole body was cut up I was
running out there and basically at a
certain point I saw this newspaper
article flash cuz I couldn't see
anything so it was just I was watching
movies and it was like boy overdoses at
Burning Man and then I was transported
over to my funeral and it was me in the
casket and all my family members were
crying my Aunts Uncles Mom Dad sibling
and they were all like oh he was such a
good kid but he did so much drugs and
and I did do a lot of drugs at that time
and that summer I had gotten kicked out
of my house and that summer I did hard
drugs every single day and sold hard
drugs to survive and so you know I had
this experience and I was on the ground
I remember coming to on the ground and I
was I thought my brain was destroyed but
my body was still going so I was on the
ground hitting my head against the
desert floor trying to pull my brain
open to pull my brain out of my head
trying to rip my head open and um it was
one of those experiences where I could
have died from that and I ended up
running through the desert I was so high
I didn't know what Burning Man was or
what I was but I was out running into
the desert in the dark of night freezing
cold and essentially what happened was I
could have died out there I was miles
out in the middle of the desert I had
covered in cuts my head was warped out
at a certain point I saw the light in
the distance and I said I got to go to
the light and so I went back came to the
party survived anyways I didn't know
where I was these people found me they
nurtured me that's Miracle did you
survive that it's crazy and um I was
feel like I was the right place for that
to happen to me because if that was in a
street let's say in the middle of there'
be cars hitting me and different things
and when I came back and hopped over
that fence I was literally running into
this party 60,000 people and I'm butt
naked I'm like what the cuz I came
down enough I could see again and then
literally a police car pulled me over
while I got in like did you just sneak
in I'm like I'm naked how where would I
have come from and then I went in and
yeah these people anyways they I started
crying after a few hours cuz I couldn't
find anything my brain was scrambled I
didn't know what was anything you see I
was just walking and I started kind of
collapsing in on myself and then
essentially this lady saw me she's like
are you okay I was like no I'm not okay
and she's like what's the matter I'm
like I lost all my stuff and she helped
nurture me give me some water some
cookies gave me this big cloak and then
eventually I came down enough where I
could remember where I was staying and
they helped find the place for me cuz I
lost the perception of where it was once
the man burns and long story
short I'm here today I survived that and
that was a turning point the next
morning I woke up and my brain was
scrambled my body was cut I missed the
whole point of going to Bernie man on
this trip and I woke up I said holy
I am alive and I have a second chance to
live Ethan are you listening yeah I am
actually are you you gaming right now I
well I just I don't get much opportunity
to play this why are you gaming
right now bro we've come so far we had a
therapist come in we've gone through so
many different things okay okay okay
sorry look at look at us look at us
Ethan look at me in the eye sorry sorry
sorry sorry I listening you had that you
had a second lease on life I woke up
with a second chance and what did I do
it wasn't about saying I'm not going to
be an addict what I did is I filled my
addiction with something else I became
addicted to making art and music and I
already did that but report everything
did you know I smoked crack one time
yeah I heard the story okay you're the
guy who smoked crack one time and then
and didn't feel it yeah he didn't feel
it it didn't count but I will say this
Ethan have you tried crack um I'm not
going to get into that no I never did
crack I smoked a lot of cocaine before
but it's not the same it's not free
right I don't know I'm not sure but
anyways you and I Ethan we're not so
different m- and hila you and I are
actually not so different that's true
and I want to say this I love your
passion for your art I really and I
admire the same about you and I'm so
impressed and Teddy fresh has inspired
me to want to make ABC alien boy
clothing and I want to say this you guys
both inspire me a lot with your
incredible talent and Ethan you've got
her she's very special yeah yeah thank
you and uh you guys are amazing and I
just want to say thank you for the years
of letting me come on the show all the
Goofs all the gags and this is the last
time I'll ever be on the
podc you know it's over I'm going to ask
you actually so when you came
to were you did you did you come abouts
in a hospital where were you I was in
the desert when you but you said you
went in a police car how did that happen
no no I I eventually when I was running
out there I was trying I was trying to
find God I was trying to find my family
and there's nothing out there I was so
delusionally lost I was thought I was
dead so I was in the midst of just this
ego death is what it's referred to often
as um but when I came back I hopped over
the fence cuz I could see it again and
then the police car just pulled pulled
me over and I could see them again I
could I was it wasn't something I
hallucinated so where so what happened
though they just were like did you just
sneak in I was like bro I'm naked like
where could I have snuck in from like
all right just let me go really and I
just ran into this party 60,000 people
just butt naked can you imagine that
it's kind of a scary frightening thing
you were only 17 yeah like you're a kid
guess that's probably wasn't legal to be
viewed W I wasn't even thinking about
that bro all those people are straight
sex offenders that cop dude it was crazy
though I forgot this moment the in the
thing but while I was having this manic
episode and this crazy experience I
thought I was giving when I watched the
burn I was like it was so beautiful I
started tearing up and then I was like I
thought I saw a BBC truck there cuz
there's people who document I don't know
if this part was real or not but I was
like seeing press there and all of a
sudden I was started talking to them and
I'm like it was so beautiful burn and I
all of a sudden I was giving a speech
and there was cameras all around me and
then there was hundreds of cameras and I
started just hallucinating and this has
never happened on LSD to me this is
that's why I think the weed edibles
played a big factor cuz like I can
definitely see that accelerating yeah
and so I was seeing hundreds and
hundreds of these cameras all around me
and newscasters and then I was like get
the away from me and I start it was
like PCV that's when like that's when I
started stripping the clothes off I
overheated and I was started and I had
this big wheel chopper bike and I was
riding it through the desert and I was
like I don't give a if I hit
anybody and I was like just full demon
mode and so
man from that moment you kind you did
you not touch drugs did you go no I used
to experiment with heroin and DMT after
that really but I had stopped hard drugs
and then I kind of tinkered a little bit
like a idiot yeah I was so
stupid but you said you with
heroin after that yeah I did but you
said also said you stop well I was in a
very different place because I wasn't
doing hard drugs and the only reason I
was exploring heroin for the most part
was that my friend was a junkie and I
was trying to sympathize with him and
understand which is no good excuse but I
was like trying to wrap my head around
it and he wasn't nearby me were you
shooting it up or smoking we just smoked
it it's called chasing the dragon tin
foil I've never done that the first
times you do it it makes you throw up so
it's not I don't and then when I really
felt it the proper times like when I
really learned cuz D the first time you
just get sick your body's like rejecting
it and then when you take it and enough
of it your eyes just roll into the back
of your head and your body overheats and
you starts feeling good to it yourself
and you can't even move like you can't
you cannot move at all I was like I'm
like dude I'm stuck like this forever my
friends like it's all good in 20 minutes
to be able to move again but it's really
it only lasts 20 minutes I mean it
depends how much you take but I mean you
you're still high after that but I'm
saying not being able to move for 20
minutes I mean I had a lot of friends uh
in college in Santa Cruz that smoked
heroin it's like very big there I wasis
when I found out that some of the people
we were hanging out with I didn't expect
them at all
yeah so when did you start doing art and
stuff from art I had already done it my
whole life so I had the outlet of it but
what I found
was with the needing to fill that time I
guess what happened was in burning man
do you mind if I eat one of my Dr
McNichol pickles yeah would you guys
care to try one of these this is fully
coer I'm good but I encourage you to try
one I had a lot of beef sticks you had a
lot these ones you don't want to try one
oh just look at how check out the back
in they're really low C I don't want it
bro but you're like the pickle guy 1,700
color what the in that pickle bro
paprika this more than prep you mind if
I eat this while I answer your question
go ahead what was the question
the question was when did you start like
pivoting into
making serious about your art right I
was already super serious I was already
signed to an agency when I went to bery
man to do What DJ I was a dub DJ oh DJ a
dub DJ I opened up okay this what this
that guy I had an opportunity at
bringman I got this this is before
having internet on your phones different
things but there was an internet bar
there um is this too loud it's probably
bad but it's fine we're we're so deep in
the episode yeah no one's watching this
show if they're here oh God he's
drinking the juice so answer your
question when I was in burning man I got
this email snail mail I went to the the
internet bar and there was a message
from my agent that said hey we got
email's not snail mail for the record
okay well for a guy like me it is what's
faster than email so they said we got an
opportunity for you to play your first
show opening up at the main stage at the
catalyst I think it was for Zed's Dead
some EDM artist and um basically they
said hey you're going to be the first up
opener and I was crazy because when I
went through that psychedelic trip I had
this realization that I felt like there
was this light that was all around me
and when I went through the psychedelic
trip I watched myself play for my
childhood and this light around me and
people believed in me to being a old
weathered out Skeleton Man I watched my
whole life play out as a drug addict
what it would have looked like mhm that
was how I interpreted it because at the
beginning I had this cheetah shirt on
and my dad when I used to race bikes
he'd be like you're fast you're fast
like a cheetah and I literally was
saying that an now I looked at the shirt
I guess I don't know at what point this
was earlier on in the trip before this
is how I thought I died basically and I
watched my life play out to this old
Skeleton Man where no one the I was in
the darkness and there was no one that
believed in me anymore and it was me by
myself I pushed away C was crazy cuz
there are a lot of like um addicts on
the street who are like super
interesting cretive of strange people I
feel like you know you could have been
one of those people easily they
recognized that addiction is a disease
now right not sure where you guys on
that but for me personally it's
certainly been something I've struggled
with and tends to run in families and
you start to see some people aren't as
prone to addiction like Ethan you smoke
crack once yeah and I just yeah exactly
and you didn't become an addict some
people smoke crack once and then they're
hooked for the rest of their life you
know mhm but I don't even think what you
smoked was
crack it was crack I watched him cook it
no I'm just joking I'm just smoking I
watch I was there I watched him cook it
bro he had like a penny cuz you need
like copper or something he's like
interesting he's a good he's a good
dude the point where I don't need
substance to feel happy you know and I
think with the making of This Album I
had such a blossom as an artist but more
importantly as a person can I say
honestly yeah I think it's your best
work stop you're the cameras are rolling
no I would I would be super mean if the
cameras were on no the we C this is over
right that the album was great I really
think everyone should go listen to it
check it out it's really good very fun I
put my heart and soul into it I made it
for three years and in that process you
know I had fully Stripped Away all
addictions and at that time I was kind
of in a crazy crazier time in my life
I'm not going to get into the specifics
of it but I was kind of getting more
wild I was living the rock star life and
um and in that process you know I
stopped weed three years ago in the
midst right around the time when I
stopped this and and I stopped alcohol 2
years ago and I stopped nicotine and and
all you're out right now totally
remember when we were with post balone
chain smoking packs of cigarettes like
those days are over so you're totally
sober now I drink coffee you know wow
good for I'm pretty addicted to coffee
but I thank you nothing wrong with
coffee no but I will say this it's a
journey and we're always learning and
we're constantly evolving but it's like
trying to figure out what works for us
what doesn't and I've been really
focused on like how do I take care of my
vessel how do I try to maintain this
this is our one body and I know it's the
corniest ship but it's like Ethan I'm so
proud of you for how far you've come in
that's what I had too you know I was
getting to the point
where I I know I was getting big it's
crazy when I look back from a year ago
how big how I was bigger even than I
remember you know you you even hate
yourself more you eat more people talk
about you and you like and it's an
addiction it's an addiction sugar is
crazy but I knew that that's why I drink
slime there's no sugar in this right I
knew I was going to die if I didn't stop
that's so crazy that you could say that
and then when when we found out about
Trader's condition oh that me up
it also clicked for you right because I
felt like we were both dying at the oh
and I thought I had like lupus and
and the some much about like his diet
matters and it just makes you realize
like you're saying you got to take care
of your vessel it kind of me up
cuz I saw us like both dying at the same
time and it was really that's so scary
you actually had like a vision of
yourself dying no I just knew
I knew I was going to die if I didn't
stop like I was you have kids you have a
family beautiful wife you going to throw
it all away no I want to live as long as
possible I got you know what I
mean you can so you you've made such big
Headway so kudos to you man I'm proud of
both of us but it also scares me like
what happened with shredder he was so
young you know and uh it just sucks man
that
sometimes people just die that's
the thing I SP so much in my life trying
to understand death and make art about
death because it's such a heavy duty
thing that we can't understanding in the
the West we don't really deal with death
well somebody or some I don't know is
gone it's like now what so weird we
don't deal with that we talk it we put a
away it happens in weird places we
don't look at it we we don't talk about
it well the thing is we go to the
funeral and then we never really want to
speak about it again or we'll still
remember the person but in the East and
not everywhere in the East but certain
Eastern cultures like people who
practice Buddhism a lot of their life is
training for death so it's actually like
the exact opposite that's very
interesting but from a western lens for
me I've spent so much of my life trying
to make art around death and explore
these Concepts that are so cuz I lost
you know I became a drug addict after my
cousin died when I was in Middle School
that was when I first I was like my
friends would smoke weed and I'd be like
I don't want any part of this like I was
like goody toua I'm like no way I would
smoke lavender with them I a Post-It
notes when I was younger than that so
obviously there were some signs but when
they brought out the weed I was like
like no way Jose like I'm not about that
I learned good how didd your cousin die
he died from spirro man angitis and he
went on he was my age he was like
basically a couple eight months older
than me or something but he was my
closest cousin like he lived over the
hill and um he was a very close friend
and that summer we took him to Mexico
the first time anyone him and his
parents and stuff had ever left America
and we went on this trip and his name
was Wayne Wayne Paul Green and uh yeah
me and him were very close and it was
just wild it really me up because
we he just one day went on a trip to
Disneyland and then he went also into
some swimming thing and he played with
some puppies I don't know exactly how he
got it but it's like rapid bacterial
infection I believe and it like your
spine all normal I know and dude he
literally within like 48 Hours he his
brain dead no way it just like had like
a his ear was like messed up and then
all of a sudden it was so rapid that
like basically his mom took him to the
hospital he was already basically brain
dead by the time he got to the hospital
or something and I went and then my dad
was like like things are really serious
like you have to go say goodbye to him
that's shocking and that like and my my
dad told me later he's like my sister
said not not Wayne's mom but he was
saying his sister was like you shouldn't
do that and my dad was like no they need
to experience this and my dad was always
that way you know in the sense that is
like this is real life and he should
have the opportunity to say goodbye to
this person which I actually look he did
the right thing I feel it was but my dad
also he like he believed that that style
and I actually I think it was a smart
way like when I went to Greece when I
was four years old my dad was like you
eat meat you got to see how the goats
die and I watched them like kill the
goats because he was like you have to
see what it is to eat meat and that's
just like you know he grew up with ranch
and farmers and this is the that's
a good I think that's it is I think it's
the right way to be able to be like hey
you're going to eat meat at least know
what the hell's going on here this
doesn't just come from Magic MH cutting
back though I went to the hospital I
don't think I've ever spoken about this
before
but I went to visit him in the
hospital it was like the most traumatic
experience of my life I think I was uh
I was in seventh grade or something
pretty much just a little bit older than
Oliver Jr imagine Oliver junr two more
years older and I go to the hospital to
see my cousin and he's just attached to
all these tubes running through he's
literally plugged up to this machine and
he looks beautiful he looks like he's
just fully in asleep he looks healthy
and everyone's just crying and my other
his our other cousin was a little bit
older than us she was like you guys were
partners in crime blah and I was like
you're so strong Wayne I was like buying
myself with them I was like you're going
to make it through this man we got to go
do so much more like this is not it you
got and I was just you know and I was
like kind of like making my peace with
it as well and being like I love you so
much like trying to you know give him
encouragement obviously he wasn't really
there at that point anymore but like it
was after that point that's when I
became like oh wow like I was like you
know what my mindset was it was like you
know I could die at any second cuz like
you know I'm probably like nine I don't
know what middle school is seventh grade
maybe 9 years old maybe 10 years old I
don't know if it's older maybe 11 or
something but like I'm like I could die
at any second you know talking about
Shredder it's like you could die at any
second so I was like well I want to see
what this world has to offer and that
was almost I think an excuse that I made
to be like yeah it's all good to try
that and then I I realized like I was
kind of like escaping and trying to
escape that pain and same year my
Grandpa died and the same year another
uncle died and so it was like a
situation where there was a lot of death
and back to what we were speaking
earlier it's just like so much of my
life has been trying to process death
and understand it and prepare myself
from the Western lens you know it's
like excuse me especially when it's like
something so
unfair shout out Wayne what do you say
like your cousin it's just so unfair how
do you deal with that it does feel
unfair that's like it's hard it's hard
to stomach it I know there's fairness is
like an invented concept right like I
think life is inherently unfair there's
no rules but it's hard to get through
that feeling of like just it's so
unfair you know like why did
this beautiful
young you know person have to do
that why just why what kind of world is
this you know like why do 5-year-old
kids get leukemia why right so hard to
wrap your head around any of it yeah
there's there's no God bro
well you know the way that it's
perceived in in the Buddhist culture is
that we're basically and I don't know
the entirety don't take this word for
word because I know nothing but I did a
class to try to understand Buddhism at
College because I didn't my brother's
explores that I'm not going to speak
much about him but I will say I wanted
to understand because my brother is
exploring that
and I was trying to study and then kind
of a lot part of the idea is that we're
just to be a human is suffering and such
immense suffering you know like it's
like trying to
create trying to to practice Detachment
and not be to attach to things because
attachment leads to suffering but if you
detach yourself too much away from
everything then you can actually create
suffering for others as well in a
different way so I'm not saying anything
necessarily is the right way of going
about it but I notic that the mindset
I'm not saying this is how they see it
but this is what I interpreted from the
class was that basically like this is
almost like to be trapped in some form
of like a hell realm because the
suffering is so immense as a human and
we all suffer so much and I think the
reality is that when we see online and
all the hatred that we get as people
online there's so many dude you you and
I know just as well I would never want
to put you through that for any reason
that was not my intention you're good
man I don't even read the
comments cuz it's so dark but people are
in such negative places in their lives
are so they're suffering so much the
misery loves company and they're trying
to bring others down with them and
they're just thinking oh like this
person is so evil they have this
perception but they don't know anything
about these people and it's just such a
like the internet's a very dark place
and what I realize is I remove myself
from the internet I really stopped using
it for like five months this year when I
was like living in Brazil recording this
album in Rio de Janeiro like in Serbia I
wasn't on Tik Tok I'm like living and
what I realized is the real world is so
much more epic and special and so I try
to obviously I have to amp back into
social media as the album Cycles happen
the only way that people hear the music
otherwise it's just I just wasted three
years of my life or actually my life's
work dedicated to Creation that led me
up to this point so you could say my 30
years of creation long story short very
interesting you know seeing the
difference between online and seeing the
difference between the real world and
one story I want to share which I've
never spoken about was like as I've
become more famous and I don't like to
use the word iname grosses me out and
the whole concepts of it is just
horrible to me it's like gross but
there's a cost for everything and for me
as an artist to make the life's work be
making the impact I have to reach people
and the goal is to inspire people so if
I don't do this stuff then there's no
way people are going to find it so the
whole thing is just a wasted effort you
know I'm just making something and I
could make a contribution instead I'm
just you know almost being selfish or
you could say you know doing nothing to
move forward Humanity or help people
from their suffering at least so long
story short I started having crazy
situations I went from with life goes on
like probably from no followers on Tik
Tok to 10 million within a two Monon
span or something like that and then
like with miss you the next one it went
from 10 million to 15 million in another
couple months span obviously there was
time in between those but seeing like
and I went to Africa when life goam went
off and I was in Morocco finishing the
cowboy album Cowboy tears and then I
went to Egypt and when I had returned I
went to a friend's wedding in Utah and
everything changed I that's when it
really happened it spiked off and before
that I was on the phone I was seeing it
but I didn't really go outside and I
talked to Tik Tok I was like how fake is
this stuff how many zeros are you guys
adding on to it they're like no this is
real I was like yeah sure I'm sure the
label just puts some number adds
the number up or whatever and then like
when I returned from Egypt and I was in
Utah in the middle of nowhere and like
my friend's wedding and we had this
dinner afterwards and like the whole
everything had shifted because the chefs
started coming out people started coming
into the restaurant every family in the
every single person in the restaurant
was asking for pictures and they're
bringing it was my friend's wedding and
I was they brought me a cake not my
friend I was like hey it's my friend's
wedding like and they're like we don't
care they like actually said that to my
friends it doesn't matter they were in
good gesture in heart to me but it was
kind of like whoa crazy long story short
I started seeing how people started
acting right so that's not the story I
want to share but I want to share this
one story of seeing like how things
started shifting crazy and one point I
went out um and I went to a bar and I'm
sober so I just like I'm hanging out
with some other people some of them were
sober as well and we're just like oh
let's hang out after this festival and
it's other artists and we're hanging and
this dude comes up to me and he's like
dude oh man I love you so much dude
you're such a legend blah blah blah and
then he walks away and then this girl
comes up she's like that's my boyfriend
he's a liar he he hates you so
much anytime I play your music he
literally says turn this garbage off
blah and then so like I'm like all right
that's pretty wild cuz like you think
about that and you're like like that's
crazy that that's the dude who's saying
like turn this off every day to her
and being like this guy and then it
wasn't that this dude came up again
maybe an hour later he's like yo let me
get you a shot blah I'm like oh I'm
sober I'm good dude he's like oh and I
already know this now about this guy and
he's like bro like man your is so
epic like I love your music and
then Flash Forward like an hour later
and right before I'm about to I'm
leaving the thing and he's like bro can
I get a picture like I'm like and he's
like talking to me and then I gave him a
picture cuz I'm like sure whatever yeah
will give you the picture and then he's
literally like bro I live for people
like you he like looks me in the eyes he
like I he's like he said some crazy
story about something about 30 people
they knew died that past couple years or
something he's like bro I I live for
people like you and that's the same guy
who hates my guts you know what I mean
so what what did you extract from that
like um I think it's just that there's a
very big difference between hiding
behind a screen and what you would say
compared to how you would react I think
when someone sees someone and they
become a little more humanized like oh
this is a person all a sudden this
character that we portray or the way we
present ourselves or whatever we're
doing online like that starts to shift
and I think there's that there's another
component of like Star Struck and people
like they don't know and all of a sudden
it's like a drug to them they're getting
this endorphin rush because and I don't
know if it's that but I'm saying there's
a mixture of factors and it varies from
and I notice a lot of people that I can
tell they're not a fan but they're like
oh like my little brother will freak out
blah blah and I'm like you're probably a
hater
like that you're I know somebody that
likes you exactly you're
like sometimes yeah I'm like oh okay
we'll take a picture watches you all the
time or like you know yeah somebody they
know watch I don't watch you no your
TR I don't watch that but one
of my dumb Friends does I'm going to
send a picture well and then you see the
more extreme versions of it which I
never really talk about either but you
get the have you guys ever encountered
the autograph hounds never those are the
scary I've only been I've only been
asked to autograph something like two or
three times only like at the end of a
live show or a meet people will bring
stuff they want you to send but so
there's these eBay sellers they're
called autograph hounds I guess I don't
know the exact term but that's why I've
researched them a lot cuz I wrote a
movie and there was autograph hounding
as part of it but I I've had very gnarly
experiences these people they wait for
you at the airport when you go they
somehow know someone at the airport they
know your flight time they bring like
seven vinyls and they're like yo like
and you're like I'm like I'm not signing
these like I know what you're doing
they're like no I'm a huge fan I can
name you 10 songs right now they like
research you and find this stuff and
their whole job is to sell these
autographs cuz I don't really do much
autographs I only do normally OT for the
for stuff that's tied to like it's just
like a simple initial and then I do my
real signature this is the scooter
signature which is like the official one
I do when I meet someone so long story
short these people are scary
like I've had them randomly show up into
the show they somehow snuck behind the
stage in Australia one time and then I
flew across the country and then the
same dude was waiting for me in a lounge
W he's like stalking me AC across the
entire country of
Australia and then they just like sell
it after they sell it but how much does
it go for okay so I've seen ones that
are like 500 bucks obviously they're not
worth much this is $89 or whatever but
like their whole day they've spent money
researching uh know they buy the vinyls
then they spent all this time
researching you they've driven from God
knows where to get flying across a
country to find me and I've had extreme
levels of it where these people get very
aggressive and if you don't say yes they
started like coming after you and I've
been chased in cars many times four
different see that these arey where it's
like I didn't and one time when I I was
there's an experience where was a
festival uh not some kind of show I was
very sick and I was with this girl and
we were going to the hotel after someone
I was seeing and this guy was coming up
to me he like he he was I was at the
venue leaving and he was like yo let me
get a picture uh no they asked for the
the signature then they want the picture
to verify the signature as well and also
they can do these things like write it
out to me and then they can wipe off the
name because there's certain sh you can
just wipe off a Sharpie so you don't
need to like whatever they're like make
it out to me like making it like feel
like they can't sell it again long story
short though this person was outside the
venue and I signed someone's earlier and
I was like I didn't really realize what
it was I was just walking and trying to
get by them and long story short this
dude gets in the car chases the Uber I
get to the hotel he gets out of the car
he's like oh over please sign this I'm
like bro I'm really sick I'm not
interested like I don't want to do any
signature stuff right now and he's like
sign this I'll pay you 20
bucks I was like no I'm good man I don't
I don't feel good right now I'm not
doing this I'm done working for the day
he follows me into the hotel room or the
hotel lobby and he's like you're a
nobody staying in this shitty
ass hotel and the girl with us like call
the police it was just like so all these
people in the hotel are just like
looking at us staring and I've had
instances where they I would did a uh a
massage my last tour Across America and
I was the the autograph pounds found me
in a few places and one of them I was
doing a massage under someone else's
name and I think that the masseuse
tipped them off or something cuz they
disappeared from a little bit a little
too long it was a weird situation and
when I came out there was two dudes
waiting for me they're like Oliver blah
I'm like oh not interested cuz now I'm
just like I have no meter for
this I'm not signing anything like I
don't give a and it makes it hard
cuz people are fans potentially like I
was coming back from Red Rocks not to
Sidetrack but there's people who want
signatures and they're like we flew to
Red Rocks and we have the I'm like are
you sure you're not an autograph Hound
like what's up but they're like I have
to give certain people the benefit of
doubt they got one thing I feel a little
bit on their autograph Hound watching
this turn it off I I don't even sign
anymore because of this if you look
it up like Dave Gro different people
they don't sign this you know
because people there's a huge business
around this but and know as I was saying
like I was they they followed me to a
private massage under someone else's
name and then they're waiting out and
then I'm like I'm like getting to
the Uber and the Uber driver is like hey
I'm like on the phone with my my manager
my tour manager being like yo what's up
with this like there's these people
waiting did you how could they have
found this out and then like just trying
to be like yo I don't know what's about
to go down and then basically the driver
of the Uber is like yo hey there's this
silver car following us right now and
like we're going like and this happened
multiple times like I can think of at
least it's honestly more than four it's
happened in Mexico it's happened in a
lot of different places in America
mainly America but they follow you and
if you run a red light they run a red
light if you flip a UI they run a UI
they cover up the license plate
and then if you I I i' why don't they
just kidnap people that finish that
story though I ran backwards on the
wrong way on a street so that I could
get into the venue a secret way and they
followed us on the wrong side of the
road and I've had other times where
filmed them with my phone from behind
the seat and they started flipping me
off and they started writing notes
they're like if Will you sign it when
you get to the Rock and Roll Hall of
Fame or just taunting me they're like
you uh what was it they were like your
music sucks just whatever stuff
that's like they just try to taunt you
at a certain point and like I'm like
trying to get a haircut to go somewhere
and then like I can't even go it was the
time where I was getting bull cuts at
Super Cuts I couldn't even get into the
Super Cuts cuz it was just scary if you
feel very scared so I was like it's just
one of those things where like you see
the effects of it and people in their L
they're like oh man I wish that I would
be loved or I wish that maybe this this
would be you know they feel lonely in
general we feel lonely and people think
if you become loved universally as a
celebrity whatever that everything is
going to be better but like you just get
more lonely you know and this album
alienating it is and I've felt Rapunzel
up into this Tower where it's
like I can't even go out I can't
experience my friends are going out and
I'm like I'm sometimes I'm just let go
and let the guards down and especially
when I'm in other countries I don't mind
it as much because I feel excited that
I'm in this place like Egypt and
I'm like holy these people like
want a picture I'm like that's epic I've
never been to this country in Brazil I'm
riding in the Subways and to meet fans
there in the underground Subways is like
a legendary for me I'm like that's cool
after a while you get sick of it but
there's a magic component overseas in
America I'm like not as excited and in
general you just start to feel the
weight of it being a job and if you're
going to go outside you're working that
day right you're do I guess I think
there's an aspect to yours that is more
um more heavy than what ours is is cuz
people don't really want from us
when they come everyone that we see is
like nice but I think as a performer M
what you you're you you're commod you
you have like a commodity there where
people can get your signature and people
are buying that dude a fly just died in
my slime yeah it's cuz it's made of
pesticide bro no way we got to
save him I'm going to put him in my Dr
McNichols pickles cap I don't like I
don't kill bugs or anything so I don't
want him to die but he's he's bleeding
out can we get something so I can save
this little dude we have limited time
we're on it we're on it we're on it uh
you can fish them out with the tissue
that's how I do it you can pick up your
bottle slime
at all right my my guy just came and he
said we have to go to the airport
basically I'm about to go to Indonesia I
would I want to talk for hours I love
you guys I'm super grateful I'm going to
save this fly before I leave I don't
know if it's going to work can we get a
shot of this can we get a closeup you
help save this come on camera save this
on this camera's flying in camera's
flying
in flying in hurry guys he doesn't he's
dying he's stand by stand by we got to
go fast okay if it gets on will this be
Community guidelines I mean this is like
kind of violent take him to the sink get
that shot but anyways I want to say
thank you guys so much I wish we could
talk for more but I I have to go to
Indonesia tonight what time is it it's
4:50 I haven't packed yet I'm going for
the rest of the year I haven't even
begun be kidding me no I swear to God I
got a new bag it's like this giant and
I'm going to fill it up with my new
Teddy fresh thank you for the gear all
right we can always mail your stuff with
and I'm going to I got some shirts there
too today so thank you you saved
it my God Round of Applause can you show
this but get in more get alive you're
you just saved
wow it can't fly yet oh my God you're
you're an
angel all right you guys I love
you both I love all of you guys album is
out thank you oh wait the last let me
say on the album is the the album the
only message I wanted to get across with
this album sensitizing to what we spoke
about is that we all feel lonely and the
goal of this album is called alone in a
crowd and it's just a reminder that even
though you may feel
lonely if you look around everyone
experiences loneliness even you guys
even when you have a couple and you're
in like you still go to sleep with your
own thoughts in your head and to be a
human is a lonely experience and just
remind you guys that hey this album is
really to remind myself even hey even
though you're lonely we're all lonely
together and it makes it just a little
bit less lonely and it's Human
Experience it is so uh let's see not
Olive Tree it's olivertree music.com for
couldn't afford the real go on the tour
the album is out called uh alone in a
crowd and um one more thing here um we
didn't get to watch this one yet I don't
think I know you have to go but yeah put
it on I know one more time I just wanted
to I just have people telling me cuz I'm
like I I'm like oh yeah I have to film a
tour promo I know there's just this one
I want to ask you about this one I
thought you played this one it was fair
with their friends you didn't play
by no no no we didn't watch this
[Music]
one I wasn't expecting that me neither I
was waiting for it I was trying to be
polite Oho I produced this one by myself
with my my production company alien boy
films and I'm really proud cuz the label
said they never had an artists fully
produce their own video from scratch I
work as a producer on other stuff but
basically long story short they didn't
even have a system in place what the
is this bro you cannot be
serious this is how you want to end this
episode I wanted to ask you why did what
why the artistic decision well all right
first of all I'm more into body work so
not just chiropractor work but my my
father does run a he's a physician and
he does chiropra Doctor yeah your dad's
a chiropract where do you think I got
the name Dr McNichols pickles dude your
dad's a chiropr my name's Oliver nickel
my do my dad is Dr MC nickel is your dad
a chyo he is yeah and he had actually
multiple suits for
malpractice please don't tell me you're
with me I'm being serious but
before I leave I need you guys to each
do one thing for me try one bite of my
world's famous Dr McNichol Pi or One S
try it it's making me uncomfortable it
would mean so much to me and I think you
should have a little sip too because we
do a paprika mix in here and it's you go
for it and then tell me just these have
been tested on animals that are pregnant
and there's no side effect
so are you going to you can take that
outfit I'm taking it I'm taking those
pants are kind of Epic I are these me
you can have them if you want they're
not Teddy fresh though so I'll take them
I like they're just nice pants it's good
I kind of want I kind of want those
pants back actually you can have
everything but I want the pants back I
pants I like those pants good pickle and
you know what I really want aiie too bad
too bad you can't take that I'm taking
him that was expensive man yeah I know
it is I'm taking it home all right so
Oliver tree is going to fly to our
Indonesia I want say seriously like just
congratulations on everything and really
proud of you for getting through the I
wish you didn't require the series
getting through like Santa Cruz hardship
like that is crazy thank you and
congrats on making it to America and
finding the love of your life thank
you love it's all love
here we meant to start serious but we
ended serious yeah I think we can just
cut the video up and don't throw these
wigs this real human hair dude well I'm
giving I think we can recut the video up
and move some stuff around maybe it's
live no it's not you said it wasn't
going to be live it's live we way I can
literally open it for you right now
watch no do not open it right now you're
joking you're trolling me tell
me you're joking come look it's the real
deal
Oliver tree live back in the hey
bro that's a got him hold on nice
dude oh you walked right into that one G
the old purple watch it again wait leave
it up Ethan I want to watch that again
do I have no sovereignty over my body
can we open it up again just cut the
video
up real human hair I have Sovereign over
my body can the video up and
move did what dude way I can literally
open all right you guys I don't know
what's happening it's like an Inception
thing but now we're watching the podcast
while it's live and I think no one's
watching at this point we've lost all
viewers yeah everybody's gone I actually
just ended the stream a while
ago that was the best clip you ever had
on this shitty little podcast that good
I'm going in for another all right bye
everybody oh goodbye bye everyone we
forgot Premier rectangular don't put
this song on turn it off hold on
let me show you a real artist trying to
end on a positive note on a positive
note by and hopefully this inspires you
this is a huge scoop um Sean Steven uh
wait was it Shan Weasley Sean St he's
giving us the premiere the big premiere
of the rectangular V video so Feast your
eyes
Oliver you could learn a thing or two
about shooting a music
[Music]
video what is that take a little goate
before I
dip you guys want to join
me FDA approved go oh my new
product super
[Music]
good what happened to my
slime it out you tossed my slime nobody
throws out my slime shut up bugs
and flies and
dude bro are you premiering this right
now 6 hours into the episode this is the
world premier I know I me earlier
appreciate it so this is really quick
before I dip I'm going to do something
very brave dud you I'm going to take
goatee grow this is with slime Steven's
time bro wait You' had is my moment time
this is his world premere has been
flying
in and I'm going to do the dangerous
thing of taking you guys want to do one
with me it just looks like vitamin I
can't when I'm that's just a vitamin
D we did with
animal we
[Music]
rolling we see you this vitamin D or e
oh okay yeah chugging it bro
yo
y can you can you share the attention
with somebody else man this is a big
moment for
sea you're looking quite circular
actually was
oh all right you guys well I'm going to
Bali I wish I could hang good luck it's
almost over Dude I wish I could hang for
hours we could probably do like the
10hour episode there's 1 minute left
just be respectful please oh sorry I
didn't even realize you were watching a
video yeah this is the world premiere so
what's the
connection that he's a real music artist
he's dope I'll give him that he's better
than the I'm putting sounds good
right yeah you guys know him he's your
friend he's a friend of the show I wish
you guys do something like this for me
when you going to plug one of my songs
that's what we've been doing the whole
time man how much more what if you guys
started playing for other guests though
you know we bring the only way I can
plug it more is if we name our son
Oliver Tre album out December something
I would love that well it's out today
just came
out yo everyone's a
box he found another rectangle well this
reminds me of a group that I recently
signed to alien Boy Records super
computer they're featured in The Essence
video and um I'm getting similar Vibes
honestly but I only thing I'll say about
that is they'll be releasing and I'm
announcing this for the first time on
the H3 podcast they will be releasing an
EP their debut EP and the first single
comes out next Friday so be warn super
computer the only feature on my album
they featured on Essence they're
incredible producers and uh they're
coming as the first release outside of
ol Tree on and congratulations to Shan
Stevens for that incredible World PR I
am that was the
premiere I tried telling you
I said share the Limelight it's his
world premier you were playing his stuff
on song I thought you were trolling me
no he sent it to us it's have to redo
yet you have to do it when I leave you
played again I already played it I don't
done it's been
premiered I would not do that you can't
put the premiere back in the D the goate
gr is hitting me right now I love you
guys both thank you for everything
thanks bye everybody have a good weekend
see you Monday see you Monday everybody
t
[Music]
rectangular and you are a circle I am
rectangular I'm a lost soul I am
rectangular